[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody
welcome back we're doing it is the last
stream of
the year
it's been an incredible year
it's been a busy year it's been
stressful
um it's been fun
and I wanted to bring some friends of
the channel on and review 2022 and how
it went for them all these people are
very very good friends of mine I've
worked with them
um for a while now in many different
fats facets of creativity of life even
and
um you know they're all freelance
creatives very much like yourselves so I
want to talk to these guys and kind of
pick their brain about how their year
went and what they do to plan for 2023
because I think it's very very very very
important to take time to reflect on how
the Year's been
so that we could better prepare
ourselves for the next year but we're
going to be chilling we're going to be
hanging out today
um there's no art today we're just we're
just having a good time we got a lot of
people in the chat
um Edge I see you yeah
yeah amazing amazing amazing you've got
some good artists up in here guys so
let's switch over let's introduce our
guests let's get right into it because
we're hanging out today
all right yes what an awesome group of
people
um man all right so first up here you
all know Winbush you guys if you're
you know looking at any Unreal Engine
tutorials Cinema 4D you got a whole
bunch of stuff when Bush it is awesome
to have you man thank you so much for
coming down
I appreciate you brother ready for this
this live stream we got today I got my
my fake Game Boy that I got from Five
Below ready to go we want to check this
out at all but yeah we're ready to rock
wait what the heck
actually questions and we got a lot to
talk about
um we also have for the very first time
uh Mr Adam or Folly who goes by feverkin
you guys may know him as fever can the
uh the musician dude what a treat what
is good my guy
hey greetings honor to be here yeah so
if you guys don't know Adam
um I mean he's been making music for a
very long time but dude you crushed the
alternate realities
um 3D challenge Montage as well as the
moving meditations
music dude you oh man it's the music and
the renders they come together so
perfectly man it was incredible
thanks yeah it was easy to be inspired
the artwork was insane
true and finally we got Mr sotomante
himself for the also for the very first
time like you've seen him pop in but
he's the stream producer he's one of the
like main moderators on the server uh
it's good to have you Soto what's good
man
indeed yeah um I'm feeling as nervous as
I expected not more which is good
um hold up those hands let me see those
hands
no no actually you can kind of see it
I get nervous too I get nervous too man
the streams are always like
I don't know I don't know yeah it's like
yeah
it's like a good nervous it's like a mix
of excitement disanticipation so good
good happy to be here
yeah so you know we're all gonna be
chilling today
um we got a bunch of awesome people here
in the chat you guys have been with us
the entire year thank you for stopping
by these streams if you have any
questions just hit us with an at
somebody if you have a question for
someone in here okay for either one of
us and we'll do our best to answer your
question we're gonna be hanging out
today and chatting about the year so I
mean this is a question to all you guys
like
is a big it's like the biggest question
how was your year that's a lot
yeah I mean who wants to kick it off
Winbush go for it man you got it yeah
all right yeah I mean my year was I
would have to say it's pretty good like
I came into this year with a bunch of
Milestones that I wanted to hit
um I probably only missed one of those
Milestones but you know
um you know that's something we could
get into more into the show but I would
say for the most part my Year's been
pretty pretty good especially with all
the conferences opening back up doing a
lot of travel getting to meet a lot of
you know you guys out there a lot of the
artists you know NAB siggraph um went up
to Vancouver hopefully going to make it
to Asia in 2023 so yeah the traveling
party's been great this year
how do you balance
you know being on the move like that and
then also making a bunch of tutorials
and doing work outside of that
um yeah not a lot of sleep
for the most part I mean oof I don't
know once I get something in my head
it's just hard to not see it to the very
end if that makes any sense so like if I
have like a tutorial idea it's like I
can't stop until I bang it out or you
know if I have client work usually I
take on client projects that inspire me
and so it's like I want to see that
through to the end so it's hard for me
to like stop my work hours nine to five
it's like I want to see this thing
through so I'm just always like full
steam ahead
yeah I could be very very uh similar it
is it is tough
um you know being on a schedule like
running a YouTube channel you gotta
schedule and you post a whole lot I know
Adam you you release music that's your
thing right so like it's very similar
it's a obviously a creative field and
you're like how well you do is kind of
kind of based off of how the audience
enjoys it right like that's a lot of
pressure how do you how do you manage
that Adam
um I have learned it's more about how
you manage your expectations and
I mean at this point it's kind of like
the system I have in place kind of uh
permits me the luxury to kind of like
take the time and make sure I like what
I'm releasing or you know if there's a
deadline of course you you got to meet
the deadline but uh you just show up and
you apply
you apply you do the best you can and
that's just that's what you do you do
the best you can and you you trust that
uh your intuition that you've acquired
throughout you know working on your
craft is serving you every step of the
way
absolutely yeah absolutely
um I don't know I I feel personally like
I've been moving and Adam we talked
about this but like we I I feel like
with the schedule it's so tough to
foresee what you know the next quarter
is going to look like or even the next
video because I'm so focused on what I'm
doing at this point and it's hard to
like
it it's hard to innovate
I feel like I'm in kind of on autopilot
this year a little bit you know just
doing what I know I can do well because
I gotta do it within a quick
turnaround you know and that's
oh yeah it's very relatable I think for
a lot of creative
people I mean you kind of figure out
something that works and
um
you know once the ball starts rolling it
kind of can be hard to stop it and uh
like re-examine the ball that's even
rolling you know because yeah you do
have to sometimes take a pause if you
want to experiment or pivot in a
different direction and
um I don't know sometimes that is kind
of scary to do that
absolutely especially when you're like
the bills come in based off of the work
that you do that people like and you're
like well shoot if I'm trying to switch
it up like are people gonna enjoy this
are they gonna I'm gonna watch this am I
gonna be able to survive it's tough
that's right yeah it's it's very silly
very very real thoughts at the same time
yeah
so I feel like you were able to do some
cool stuff this year though like with
the photogrammetry work I felt like that
was kind of a pivot in the experimental
realm that you were able to kind of take
it and make it your own in I feel like
excuse me I felt like the community kind
of reacted to that pretty well yeah yeah
I I think switching it up is nice as far
as the photogrammetry stuff I I love it
um it it's a chance for me to get
outside too and scan some rocks scan
some trees Etc
um and I'm really excited to do more of
that stuff next year and see how that
pushes my art but um you know uh Mikhail
let me let me hit you up you know you
recently
um you moved and you're a you're in
University right now yeah right this
year has been like the biggest pivoting
thing for my like career I don't know if
I should call it a career or more like
creative I don't know but basically at
the very start of the year I was still
doing an engineering degree and I was
not enjoying it like I could you know I
could keep doing it keep doing it but at
the same time I was starting to get the
ball rolling and getting some freelance
and you know which I was very excited
for I I had already gotten a bit of it
but now it was like you know more more
stable I guess in time
um and so at the end I decided to just
leave that and I I it's like a whole
thing I moved to in a different city uh
you know living by myself I have a
roommate and it's like on the University
campus so it's been pretty easy but
still it's you know like far from family
meeting new people far from the old
friends but but yeah I'm really happy so
big big deal yeah
that's amazing well it's like a huge
change in your life like I never had the
college experience and I definitely wish
you know like part of me wishes I had
that I think I kind of got it when I
came out here to LA with Freddy and
samaniko it was very I was gonna say
that feels pretty University or college
minus like having dorm rooms and stuff
but
um yeah you got your education in a
totally different way man
yeah absolutely absolutely um and I
think it's really important that like
all of us every every creative person
out there finds a group of people that
they can you know hang out with and
learn from and grow with and you know
Mikhail like you're getting that in
school which is amazing
I mean I had like a big chunk of that I
already had online of course meeting you
a lot of people in in your Discord
um or in different places but yeah like
meeting them in person it's it's a bit
different you know because one thing I
found out is I need to find like new
hobbies because before when I wanted a
break I would do 3D art but now that's
what I'm doing in school so like I need
new hobbies uh well or or you know just
watching movies with friends or but
different stuff because if I just do the
same that I was doing before for a break
I'm just not taking a break anymore
um but yeah
too true I mean Adam like I remember you
telling me Oh you can't listen to music
when you're not making it listen to
music when you're listening on two
bombers about going into music as a job
is you can't listen to music while
you're working on music and yeah
sometimes listening to music or working
on music after working on music is not
the vibe either so
at least for me
yeah I got the same thing when I was in
school I went to the Art Institute for
my degree and um I got it in Motion
Graphics and VFX so you know we would go
through learn about compositing and you
know special effects and things of that
nature so as I was watching movies when
I was in university I got the same thing
it's like because instead of enjoying a
movie I was literally breaking down
every single shot like oh I see where
they messed up on the road or there or I
see like the lighting is kind of messed
up in that area and the Shadows should
be you know hitting a certain area and
it got to the point where people didn't
want to watch stuff with me so I kind of
learned to readjust and just enjoy you
know like movies and TV shows for what
they were instead of trying to like
analyze every single thing that came up
on the screen because he was driving
everybody around me crazy every time I
pointed something out
that's hilarious it's like when you when
you're in
you can't you can't be out
you're always in yeah yeah
um so all right Andre wants to know what
what our biggest achievements of the
year are and like I this stream is not
for that we're gonna answer we're gonna
answer your question right we're gonna
answer your question because I think it
is nice to reflect
like I just don't want to be like oh
like I'm the best blah blah blah you
know I I want to focus on like what I
can do better for next year and like
what the hardest parts were we're gonna
get into that but I also think Andra you
are correct we gotta focus on the wins
as well so let's go through everybody
we'll start with Winbush we'll go Adam
Mikel and myself
um what what is the thing that you're
most proud of this year Winbush
um two things 100 getting out my free
course on Unreal Engine five because
previously I don't know if anybody knows
I did a course that was a paid course
with the mograph.com guys and the it was
a good course for under Engine 4 but the
main thing that like tore me up was it
was around 250 bucks so you know like
the United States and First World
countries yeah that wasn't a lot of
money but I would have a lot of people
from other areas of the world hitting me
up saying like hey I can't afford 250
bucks like that's my two months income
and I really want to take your course
and so I got to talking with epic games
I got a mega Grant and I was able to
release a course this year absolutely
free for everybody through my YouTube
channel so that was something that
really meant a lot to me because now
everybody has access to that free
education so that was something that I
was most proud of and then the second
one I got invited down by epic games to
speak at their conference in New Orleans
this year so that was pretty cool
because
um you know I've spoken a lot to the
Motion Graphics Community but never to
like the gaming community and I've you
know I have an affinity for a video game
so being able to go on the main stage
down there with epic games and just
interact with a whole nother Community
that's out there I mean that was amazing
in itself so I would say those two
things right there heck yeah dude that's
huge that's huge and I take that's a lot
of work to get to that point too
especially that course my goodness
um and I mean and to speak on the main
stage too with with uh with epic that's
like
a lot of work goes into getting to that
point so that that's really cool that
you're able to get there this year
um and I'm excited to hear what you we
have planned for 2023 but Adam what
would you say
was your biggest achievement of this
year
[Music]
um
uh
this year was kind of uh
more of a sabbatical type of year for me
um so Mikhail I can relate to like
moving to a totally a whole new area and
trying to like grow your roots with like
new people and trying to find new
hobbies and stuff like that so
um
lots of personal
personal things I'm super super proud of
but you know on the music front uh
really really stoked with how moving
meditations turned out
and uh played my first show in three
years
uh so that was super rest yeah
yeah it was uh totally it was like
blowing the dust off the gears kind of
thing did it feel good to be like I
still got it
yeah more or less yeah were you nervous
getting back out there because you're
probably it's your first show because of
the lockdown right so did it feel like
you're like his muscle memory like
you're able to jump right back into it
or did you kind of get like nervous
again like man how do I kind of now it's
always nerve-wracking up and up until
the first moment like as soon as as soon
as the first
second of sound is played like all stage
fright goes away for me okay
yeah
yeah the way my sets are done right now
is like uh with the MIDI controller so
uh at least I don't have to worry about
timing and all the virtuoso of you know
playing the instrument perfectly
correctly and stuff like this
but you gotta hit those right triggers
at the right time though because then
oof it'd be true dude brutal
um now I I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna press
Adam
um
because
you now you I I said biggest dream of
the year that doesn't doesn't mean it
has to be career based you said you got
a lot of personal stuff are you
to be continued another time or uh do
you want to elaborate on in any of those
personal achievements
you can hit me with the 2B continued and
then we'll go on to Mikhail you know
maybe later
it'll probably come up naturally later
in conversation so let's hit it with the
TV continued all right sounds good Mikel
biggest achievement of the year for you
both or either personal or uh work
related
yeah
um
I upgraded to Windows
um did you really because I still have
it I did yeah I know we're keeping it at
Bay dude yeah me neither you know
seriousness
um I it was probably just taking the
decision to switch the University degree
because I like I thought a lot about it
luckily I like good friends in in my
city like also was that where they tell
you you should change so probably that
whatever you think
um side note those are some good friends
who would be like yo
you should go you should go it's gonna
be better for you
dang that's legit keep in touch with
those guys
um
for me oh man
um I had this is a wow
this is crazy because I hadn't even
thought I never think about the past I'm
like as soon as I finish something I'm
just like what's the next thing
um I'm trying to remember what the heck
happened this year uh I guess we have
two challenges every year those CH I
mean dude both of those challenges
putting out those montages the top 100
montages and even the all renders
montages like
man those are some those are some big
moments um
it's such a great representation of
everyone's art all the hard work that
went into it I'm really proud of like
you know piecing together the top 100
and like working with the different
musicians I got to work with um of
course Adam this year for moving
meditations
and like going back and forth and
hearing your music come in and being
like oh this is gonna be good I know
it's like still in like the demo phase
or like it's not mixed yet or but this
this is gonna be nice like that's so
freaking awesome like seeing something
come together like that
um is is a huge moment for me
um and I got to also work with uh miles
senzaki to point Lobo uh he did a really
cool
a piece of music for infinite Journeys
so it was cool like getting to work with
different
different artists
um and kind of learn how to collaborate
on a different level you know because
it's it's not the same when
you work with someone you've always
worked with like when you work with
someone new it's a whole new journey and
I love that it feels very fresh
um
let's see
can something big happened this year
Clinton
oh yeah I turned 31.
and hit a million subscribers on my
birthday that was crazy that was a
freaking crazy moment
is that what you're referring to no
oh thank God I got married this year
yeah
don't be mad please
say oh she don't see that I didn't hear
that part no she heard it
I was checking on Instagram just to
check if it was this year or not see you
didn't know what you didn't remember you
had a check
I'm like
so it's funny the first thing you went
to was your million subscribers on
YouTube then you're like oh yeah I got
married
nah it's my fault I said something big
that's like the number yeah it's fine
thank you thank you but yes I got
married that was crazy I was not
expecting uh
everyone's like oh yeah you know the day
you get married is like Best Day Ever
straight up best day ever it was
absolutely insane Adam you were my best
man that was a solid speech
um you referenced Resident Evil 4 that
was awesome
okay
nice yeah it was it was a good time
um I'm gonna I'm gonna turn this around
I'm gonna turn this question around
and we're gonna say
what's the thing
that you guys are trying to change
for next year
I'll start with you
let me think about it
um
probably just balancing everything
better this you know like doing it with
more Sports caring a bit more about
sleeping schedules uh just having having
better I know you're very organized you
always have like a calendar and then
post it with everything you need to do
and I I wanna do a bit more of that
because
that's hilarious he's saying that I'm
more organized dude I'm uh
I think that is good though yes striving
for organization is is a solid thing I
used to be called double book jones
because I would
I would say yes to one thing on this one
friend group and then like this other
friend would be like oh yeah totally and
I I totally forgot that I had the other
thing and I would show up late to
everything and that sucked and I became
known for that and that's not good so
um luckily for me I kind of managed to
you know not double book and things like
that but it's just like it takes so much
like I always have things I have to do
in the back of my mind is like either
doing them or haven't written down you
know yeah I feel like it just be more
chill
yeah get it out of your head onto
something
um I think that yeah that's solid that's
a solid goal
um anything else or do you should we
move on to Adam
no I think that's it what do you think
Adam what's the thing that like you felt
you could have done better this year and
like you're really trying
to improve for next year what would make
next year the best for you
oh I would say consistency for me
uh consistency and Clarity of intention
uh
yeah and when I say Clarity of intention
I think it's uh just having a discipline
of really
sitting down and sifting through my
thought thoughts to like
figure out what it is I want to do uh go
forward with creatively because I'm in a
step now where I'm working on my next
album while I'm juggling two eps
with uh two collaborative EPS with some
other artists and vocalists and uh
the album the album is tough because uh
there is no
there's no feedback loop coming from
other people it's just like something
where like it's only gonna happen if I
push forward through it you know like
you're
when you work on writing your own stuff
you know you there's sometimes it can
just be a lot of resistance to just like
sit down and show up sometimes
um it's so easy to just get swamped with
just
doing other things which still can be
good and productive but
yeah so I don't know consistency
personal consistency showing up for
myself and uh yeah working on Clarity of
intention how do you do that
like what oh uh for me it's uh
incorporating uh taking my meditation
practice more seriously uh taking my
journaling more seriously
um allowing myself to enjoy life more
like Mikhail you're talking about that
balance uh 100 very very important
because we are the creative vessel and
you do have to take care of the vessel
if you want the vessel to produce any
fruit
so
um yeah I don't know I
just
trying to live as authentic of a life as
possible and uh working 100 of the time
for me is not an authentic life but also
uh going out and just doing things for
fun all the time is also not my idea of
an authentic life so something I've been
entertaining lately here's the question
if you could
would you
just go off and have fun and
the zero repercussions like that's your
whole life is just going off and having
a good time
everything's taken care of like rant
blah blah don't have to worry about it
oh it really it comes down to how you
define what a good time is you know just
doing what you want in the moment all
the time
no that sounds awful actually I think uh
you will get to a very Hollow Place
where uh you just feel like something is
missing
um because doing what you want in every
given moment is like staring at your
feet while trying to go towards a
destination you have to look ahead to
know where you're going and I think
always just uh indulging in your
passions
um or whatever your your hobbies I don't
think that's gonna actually get you
anywhere
um of course it's healthy to do at times
but living a life that I don't think is
actually healthy or good or even happy
in the long term in my opinion
yeah I I agree it's like
I feel like you'll to be like fulfilled
you should be trying to achieve
something you know and if you're not if
you're always I don't know then an easy
example is on social media it's just
like what it's you know like there's a
reason why we fight being on our phones
instead of creating personal projects
it's not like if you don't create
personal projects you're not gonna have
a job or anything but sometimes it's
just you know although as you said yeah
that's a good that's a good
good point I I never thought about doing
what you want as
going through life with your with your
head staring at your feet because like I
in in a way I do feel the same with like
trying to keep up the schedule on the
YouTube channel
the train is moving at full force but
I'm just playing one track ahead of it
you know one track at a time and it's a
panic and a stressful thing to like keep
laying the one track the one track the
one track and I know there's a giant Gap
coming up in a couple months in the form
of a giant 3D Challenge and like you
better figure that out and like you
better get some tracks over that because
you know you better and like but I'm
like I don't have time like I have to
keep doing these one tracks right here
because the train is moving too fast uh
it's crazy yeah
um but
we'll get back to I heard someone I
heard someone Define I don't know where
I read it or where I heard it but I
heard someone say discipline is
on now that I'm trying to say it I'm
gonna forget it discipline is uh
doing what you want
giving up oh
shoot this is so annoying yeah I bet
someone in the chat might know where I'm
going with it's like doing what you want
most at the expense of what you want to
do right now
no there's supposed to be like a sub
bass drop when it's said correctly that
you're like oh okay that's the truth but
I didn't I didn't say it right but it's
something like that it's like giving up
what you want now for what you want most
[Music]
yeah okay so I mean that sounds yeah I
think that was it yeah do you guys feel
the sub bass drop a little I heard a
little bit of it yeah a little bit okay
um when Bush we're we're gonna I want to
ask you the same question but before we
do I gotta shout out my boy Devon
Williams he's in the chat today so Devon
me Devon and Adam all grew up together
in Georgia ah nice
um
Devon's in the chat right now he just
hit hit us with the super chat too
that's amazing
yeah Yvonne hey there dude we would just
get together and like dude Devon's New
Year's parties at his parents place oh
my God those are the best those are the
most wholesome parties like
cheese man it just truly was fun for the
whole family but that was the time that
Brett body slammed a fire out of the
lawn
because the fireworks we were setting
off were just too big and Brett Brett
just went for it that I will never
forget that
[Laughter]
crazy
um shout out Stefan all right Winbush
Winbush Winbush all right so
what what what are you trying to do for
next year that you didn't quite hit the
mark on this year what would make next
year the best year for you
yeah I think um instead of being so
technical working more on myself you
know like mentally and physically like
pre-pandemic I was actually in really
good shape as when I actually start
boxing for charity and stuff like that
instead watch the pandemic hit I kind of
got into really bad habits you know
eating and being stationary because the
gyms were closed for two years and then
this year I canceled my gym membership
and I built a gym in my backyard just
because I was always jealous of like
Muscle Beach up in Venice Beach you know
how they work out outside and everything
so I built like a fully functional gym
outside been um working out been getting
over some of my health problems because
like during a pandemic you know caught
covid and developed like a heart issue
and stuff but started working back out
getting back into that routine and
actually overcame that so no longer
having to really take the medication and
stuff like that but that's huge eating
habits are still kind of bad so trying
to bounce that out a little bit more
because like my kitchen is literally
right here it was just oh snap like you
guys are you guys are talking about
discipline right it's like kind of just
putting those blinders up being
disciplined and kind of always realizing
my goal every time I want to you know
snack on something unhealthy and yeah
just really trying to work on that and
get back to where I used to be but I
think next year I'm just going to be
more focused on myself and especially
with travel and stuff you know like it's
not like Cove it's gone you know and I
actually caught it going to New York so
it's like I want to make sure that I'm
in the best physical
um
think that I could be in just in case I
do get sick it's easier to fight off
those diseases and stuff rather than you
know if I'm not in good shape you know
dude 100 yeah I think
our health is everything it's kind of
all like Adam you're talking about that
vessel like how can how can we
produce anything
good or or neutral whatever
um if we if we like
if our bodies aren't healthy so
that that is a huge one that's a big one
for me too like I feel like I I
neglected
I I know I neglected a lot this year
um like
the yoga working out
um I did a lot of rock climbing but
you know I definitely feel it from not
doing yoga
because my buddy Cliff he got me into
yoga
and like so far into yoga that like we
went to teacher training and everything
uh me and my remember you taught it I
can't mugraft that one year yeah that
was that was awesome yeah
um and like I really like clipped my
buddy Cliff he said he he believes that
that yoga is the key to uh to your
youthfulness and I'm like dude that
makes so much sense because if you're I
think I was telling EJ this like if you
if you're
60 years old and you slip and fall it's
gonna you know what's gonna happen and
you go into the deepest stretch of the
last
40 years
dude you're tearing something you are
tearing something no matter what but if
you do yoga every week then it's just
like a Tuesday so like that's that makes
so much sense to me
um so I really want to get back into the
to the yoga routine and I think the
morning routine for me I've really
neglected it I wake up and I I make tea
thank God at least I make tea I do some
dishes and then I
get behind the computer and start
working and it's like that's
that's too much man I gotta I found that
once you get into today once you jump on
a computer it's almost like a death trap
right like once you're in it then you
get laser focused and that's where time
kind of just slips away and so what I've
been doing like I typically wake up like
five six in the morning and behind this
poster I actually have a treadmill so
what I try to do is before I even turn
on my machine or anything at least try
to get in like a mile or two on a
treadmill first thing in the morning
because I'd know once I jump on a
computer then that's going to be it for
the next couple of hours and it's hard
to break yourself away from it so I try
to at least get that routine out of the
way try to get some steps in and
everything and while I'm on the
treadmill you know it's like I can watch
Netflix on my iPad or I could do check
my emails for my phone and stuff like
that so it's like I'm still doing other
stuff but at least trying to get
something going first thing in the
morning always helps out rather than
jumping right on their computer and then
it's almost like Doomsday right it's
like okay the next thing you know is
like 1 o'clock two o'clock and you're
like shoot I haven't done anything all
day like no moving around or anything
um
yeah Adam you got like a quite a routine
set up right your morning routine
yeah no one Bush totally man the
routine's important because I can
totally relate uh I'd have a problem
where sometimes I would wake up and
the main problem for me would be the
phone like I'd immediately just get on
like social media or email
um if not I would just go straight to
the computer and then
yeah just like any um especially like
all the things for like my health my
mental health especially uh would just
get thrown out the window if I just like
made a beeline to my computer
yeah but yeah for me the morning
routines definitely looking like waking
up at the set time every time
um so for me that that does take some
willpower sometimes to wake up at the
same time every day and
um yeah Yoga Yoga really helps a lot not
only physically but mentally as well
because it's a good space to just be
with your body and
um just having a yoga practice
it really is interesting like how much
it spills over into other facets of your
life just like the amount of awareness
you have about yourself and uh just how
you're feeling that day
and then yeah journaling for me making a
habit of journaling every day has been
probably one of the biggest game
changers of my life which is something
I've journaled I've journaled for a long
time since I was a teenager right since
I was a moody emo teenager but now as an
as an adult like I'm making it a
practice to intentionally do it every
single day as opposed to just when I'm
feeling sad or super super stoked or
whatever
um so some a lot of my entries are kind
of boring but
I mean they're not for anyone they're
they're right they're for you
exactly which is what makes it so
powerful is that uh you can get whatever
thought
s that you didn't even know you were
carrying sometimes because you have to
like get out all these like top level
thoughts to get sort of the deeper level
thoughts sometimes just like yoga
something like that oh yeah what kind of
yoga are you guys doing I have a friend
that's really into hot yoga and he's
like telling me every day he's like dude
you got to get in on this hot yoga like
it's going to change your life and I've
always um I don't know I've just always
been reluctant to yoga because I'm not
very flexible but I've been trying to
get back into running because when I was
um you know when I was really in shape
like I used to do Sprints down at the
field a lot and I tried it recently in
maybe like on the second Sprint I pulled
a hamstring like right away and I'm like
I'm getting too old for this like I
gotta really start getting into
stretching because that never used to
happen before you know and it's like as
you get older it's like man you know
it's like I'm trying like in my head I'm
still like 25 but my body's like nah not
today so I hit the Sprint oh they had me
hit the ground I'm just like man I gotta
take better care of myself
yeah the muscles get tight yeah if you
don't if you don't um tend to them
yeah I was gonna ah no we haven't heard
from you in a minute Michael what's up
yeah I just wanted to point out that you
guys have it pretty figured out I for me
it's just like more General I just I'm
like yeah I should do more sports but I
didn't like haven't really done any like
concrete plan I want to do that also I
wanted to ask
um Adam do you find yourself coming back
to the things you write or is this Jesus
because of the process of writing it
that's helpful
um I mean when I get to the end of a
journal I think it's kind of nice to go
back through and see uh the patterns
sometimes see the things that have been
unresolved or just like any themes that
have been showing up in my life so to
answer your question yes
um but that's more something to like do
towards the end of each journal for me
I don't think I've ever
gone back and read the Journal of mine
and I think
that's probably the same reason
I
like I never look back
ever
and I don't think that's a good thing
like
I think the only time I look back is is
probably at the end of the year when I'm
like reflecting on the year
but like I don't I I can only I can only
gauge my year in terms of like projects
because I don't know like time is just
out the window and it's like when did
that happen I have no idea like Adam did
we go to did we go to Alaska this year
or was that last year
that was last year dang see
like what prod like I'm trying to think
like what project I was working on at
that point because I I have no sense of
time anymore it's just my head is so
freaking I'm so like zoomed in I gotta
zoom out
um
we were we were getting into I'm trying
I'm trying to get my train of thought
back here
because Michael I wanted to ask you
yeah yeah for a minute there is that it
um morning routines we were talking
morning routines yeah like Michael do
you have any morning routine situation
going on like or are you just living
that Carefree life that University life
um
I mean okay so luckily I have University
at like eight or nine every day in the
not not you know except the weekend so
at least I have that to keep me in check
yeah
um and since I'm in the uni campus I'm
like super duper close so I always end
up like cutting it right to the line but
some some days what I do is I eat
breakfast before class and other times I
do it in between classes uh so no it's
it's pretty Messy as a routine I think
but
I I I mean I'd rather have a good
afternoon routine too with her I like if
I if I'm just like productive after
class I'm happy
but yeah wait a second you are in Spain
right so you guys you guys have like
that half day break that Siesta life
going on my my okay so now that I'm
going to VFX school or however you want
to call it uh I really quickly switched
to the English class so I have a lot of
friends from other places everyone the
the first month was like oh dude you do
the Siesta you do the Siesta I
personally don't like it too much
um why but it just breaks my my day you
know like hmm okay I like sleeping and I
like being awake but the in-betweens are
like ugh I need to do my whole like now
I go to bed I close my eyes I think for
a bit until I fall asleep and when I
wake up I'm a bit foggy and I have to
just like start being awake uh I'd
rather just do it once at eight and
twice
oh so I I guess I don't know much about
it so like you literally are like all
right I'll see you guys after this nap
like that's what it's like
stand up yes it's I still stays just an
up after lunch that's it
how long you used to nap for or how long
is the break for
depends on the person I guess I don't
know oh really yeah I mean is there like
corporate is there corporate naps like
no like corporate Maps
trademark snaps
oh that's funny though you know freaking
mattress company they're like okay see
us the time and then you check the good
one don't say businesses observe siestas
like the owners will will take the nap
so the business will close at certain
certain times during the day yes that
might happen
um I'm kind of I don't know if this
affects it really but I'm kind of from
the north of Spain where it's less hot
so maybe that affects it because like
you know in the summer you might be more
like after lunch all your blood goes to
your stomach to
digest and you're like like oh in the
sofa but I don't know
um maybe in other places of Spain they
do more sisters than where I'm from hmm
yeah we need to do them here
dude I'd be down yeah I agree I mean I
probably I do it myself anyway but when
I used to work at Studios it would have
been nice to take a midday nap
especially if you have like a heavy
lunch you know it always gave me food
drama you just like you go back to work
kind of drowsy so having like that
little power nap would have been good
so I want to ask you guys a question
about like self-employed working from
home uh freelance life kind of thing so
one thing that's been a struggle for me
this year is
um separating
the work life balance and like I always
felt that I was pretty good at doing
that but this year I was not and uh
I would get this feeling where like
and maybe you guys feel the same
but I'll get this feeling where
uh
uh there's so much to do
to improve the channel to improve the
business to to improve the videos
um there's there there's always way more
to do than than not
so
cutting it off at a certain point
knowing this list is freaking massive
it's like Santa's freaking list dude
it's like it goes to the floor and it
never ends it never ends dude it's never
ending like how I have trouble stepping
away from that list
um and taking a break because like
there's just too much that needs to
happen and maybe it's a thing where it's
like I just need more help I can't do it
alone
um and I'm like trying to get there a
little bit like solomonte you know
you've helped with the streams that's
been oh my god
um I got some help in some other areas
too which has been helpful but like
I don't know I
it's like this massive list that never
ends
um and it would just make me feel better
if I just kept working
on that list as opposed to taking a
break I don't know do you guys feel
similar
yeah for me so either what happens is if
the list is short like let's say this
week I only have like two to ten things
to do it's like really two I can just
get through it but if I see that the
list is too big sometimes I get like
blocked and I just procrastinate even
the first step if that makes sense
and then if I have too many things to do
sometimes then it's fine because I'm
like oh it's infinite doesn't matter I'm
just gonna like at that point it's not
even a list you know
um but a lot of the times I just get
blocked if the list is too big so yeah
um what about you guys yeah
I kind of because like I've been doing
this really really long time and like as
you were alluding to it seems like the
list never ends no matter what like you
could have that list but there's never
any goal line in sight like I usually
try to make like yearly Milestones that
I like to hit but for the Long Haul
especially like you know we're all
entrepreneurs we all work for ourselves
and so the the ground is never going to
end you know it's like once you get to
one Milestone there's always going to be
something else that you want to kind of
achieve and for me I kind of got more
into this mentality of just go with the
flow and so that's how I was able to
kind of get that stress off my shoulders
because it's like I know I get stuff
done and I'm gonna get it done but at
the same time I can't you can't grind
your body into the ground because it's
like once you get sick or you know like
if anything happens to you then
everything that you have set out on your
list that's not yeah you know you can't
achieve that anymore because now you're
in a physical state where you can
physically do it anymore where they're
like I've had a buddy
um in VFX I don't want to say his name
but he was working
non-stop on like TV shows and big movies
and he would never ever take a break and
he was you know he's wearing his body
down and the doctors you know they kind
of told him like you're under too much
permanent stress all the time you need
to kind of take a break and
unfortunately he ended up having a
stroke a couple of years ago because of
it oh my goodness and now he can't do
any work at all right like he's in rehab
trying to relearn how to walk and do you
know simple stuff that we take for
granted so when that happened to him I'm
like I can't keep living like under this
constant pressure all the time like you
kind of have to get out of that mindset
of having that constant pressure on you
and kind of alleviate that and you know
whether it's through you taking on less
or like you were doing you're getting
more help to kind of alleviate that
pressure off you like those stuff are
vital but again it's like if you wear
yourself into the ground then that's all
going to be for not because you're not
going to be able to do anything right
yeah max out and like I I actually I I
think I've
I'm burnt out
right at the end of the year I think uh
I think I've I've I've achieved burnout
officially you gotta take a break I mean
I I told you I think at the beginning of
this year
I was under massive stress under this
one TV show I was working off her
History Channel and it got to the point
to where um I was feeling it like in my
heart and after that you know like I
went to see the heart doctor and that's
when I was I had that condition but she
was telling me you know I was due to too
much stress and you know getting over
coveted and stuff like that so honestly
I took a big chunk of this year off like
I mean I was blessed enough to have like
a good savings and you know be
financially stable enough to be able to
take a break but once I took that break
and then focused back on myself and only
taking like client jobs here and there I
focusing more just on like the YouTube
channel and my health now I'm back to a
point to where like I don't have any
heart conditions and the stress is
pretty much alleviated but it's like if
I would have kept going I could have
seen myself honestly maybe having a
stroke by this summer like it it was
that serious you know wow yeah
yeah so I mean a lot of people only
think about like exercise and eating but
your mental stress plays a big big part
into how your body functions like if
you're under constant stress then that
physically takes a toll on your body
whether you recognize it or not yeah 100
wind Bush have you ever like emotionally
burned out if that makes sense I know
you're talking about like how you were
feeling like the load and if you kept
going you maybe would have experienced a
stroke maybe kind of like how your
friend did but right in your experience
were you getting to a point where
uh you were taking on so much work you
were working so hard that
how do I one phrase this it's like
it's a pretty dark place to get to where
it's like I don't like what I'm doing
anymore yeah I would say that only hit
me this year because you know for the
most part like I get to work on cool
projects work get to work with cool IPS
and you know there's some stress there
but for the most part it's like I always
looked at the end goal but it's like
okay I got to work on this movie it's
done got paid get to see your stuff up
on the screen and that was something
that I used to you know like strive for
like okay that's the cool end result but
for some reason maybe it's because
they're coming out of lockdown but the
beginning of this year is when I finally
felt like I was probably in that dark
place to where it's just like
this is actual work I'm not enjoying it
the producers are down my back and I'm
stressed out and I need a break or else
I don't know like I I seriously thought
about is there another like road that I
want to take outside of doing Motion
Graphics like it got to that point so
that's you know I took the break and no
longer feel like that now so I think
brakes are really vital to us you know
how long was your break I'm like I'm
like dang I kind of feel similar right
now yeah what's the recipe
so I finished that job in Spring and so
I told all my clients I was going to
take the summer off
um I started doing work again maybe
around beginning of November so what
that was the summer so maybe about like
three or four months something like that
but you know like I still took on like
small gigs in the meantime I know I'm
you know kept focusing on YouTube was
doing a course and stuff like that but
um I would say yeah three to four months
was a good that was a good point for me
you know some people it might be
different but I've been working like 15
years straight non-stop so definitely
you know needed that breakthrough
awesome sorry Clinton yeah
no I'm like
or can I fit in three to four months
that's great
um I think I need that
honestly
but it's like oh I don't want the
channel to die you know you know um so
that's the tough part yeah because you
know I've seen streamers you know twitch
streamers and specifically like whenever
they take a break it's like their
numbers dip so you know I don't know if
you watch any type of like streamers or
anything like that but I watch a lot of
their interviews and they always say
that too like there's constant pressure
to always be streaming because once they
don't stream then it seems like Their
audience kind of jumps somewhere else
and so there's like that constant
pressure of being able to try to bounce
that
yeah it's just not sustainable though
it's like how
there's only so far you can go with that
uh certainly not
it's not sustainable we're all just
individuals
yeah yeah it's not a freaking like whole
team you know it's like just one person
maybe a couple people with some help
here and there but
yeah yeah
honestly for me this is great to hear
I'm sure for a lot of people in the chat
but because right now I'm like on the
other side of the pendulum where I'm
like really really excited you know I'm
meeting new people whatever but I I just
want to not swing back super
you know like a lot so I'm trying just
to load down a bit just to not get burnt
out
um because yeah I feel like if I get too
excited now I do too many projects
that's cool plus this plus that I yeah
I'm I'm afraid that I might get burnt
out in the future so it's good to have
in mind yeah yeah I think it's still
good to it's still good to have the
optimism and be excited and you know
you're still learning and being able to
take that on and um you know I would say
I'll say go for it but just always be
cognitive that
you know if you are feeling stressed or
you are feeling burnt out like take it
serious especially since you're young
like don't wait 15 years like I did to
where it got to that point like you know
definitely take your breaks and work on
yourself and just be cognitive of what's
happening around you you know because it
is very easy to just kind of get laser
focused on what you want to achieve but
yeah sometimes it's good to take this
state or take a step back and kind of
breathe a little bit
yeah yeah I think I I could see it as
like finding your limit you know like
you hit you hit the ceiling you're like
maxed out you break through the ceiling
you're like whoa it's crazy out here and
then you're like you take a break and
you're like oh I'm not going past that
ceiling again
um right and then you do it again and
you just I don't know it's like a live
and learn situation I guess but like
this is I think this is the second time
I felt like this
um it it's tough like working at
Corridor is uh
is very different than running a YouTube
channel
very very very very very different
um and like
there's ups and downs to both situations
but like I'm missing I'm I am missing
the UPS you know like the the like
I just gotta show up to work
and like have a good time and then come
home and then like do whatever you know
like there isn't that anymore
um yeah
so I feel like more is demanded of you
now oh my God
dude times it's kind of a leading
question 20
thing yeah dude it's ridiculous it's
unmanaged when you're on my own
yeah when you're in Corridor you can
feed off the energy of everyone you're
working with you know you can like have
that feedback loop
but yeah
when you're on your own like that you
have to dig deeper into yourself for
inspiration and then yeah definitely so
important to take a break
one thing that I've tried doing like
so taking my meditation practice more
seriously uh one thing I've tried this
year on the topic of health is fasting
actually I've done this yeah
yeah are you doing like intermittent
fasting or have you ever done like an
extended fast I've done intermittent
fasting in the past that's something
that I need to get back into but it
really works it really does
you tell them about tell them about how
you freaking like
healed yourself that was insane
uh yeah I used to have like a gluten and
dairy intolerance which was like so
annoying to admit but I would get like
these gnarly rashes underneath my beard
and uh I did a week of not eating food I
just drank water for a week and
um
you know I did my research before I just
like decided to do that but yeah when I
got back into eating food uh yeah like
gluten didn't cause the rashes anymore
wow that sounds chunky but I mean yeah
but I would I would like to talk about
fasting in a different regard though is
that uh it's like a very very quick way
to get a lot of very sharp perspective
on
where you're at I've done too fast now
actually I did a three day fast this
week and then yeah I did that week-long
fast back in January
and um and when I say fast not only did
I not do food but I didn't even get on
my computer
and um it's just very it's like aggro
rest basically like that was just really
in bed
um the whole day so it's like you know a
lot of contemplation and uh when you
come back from when you break you're
fast uh you definitely notice yourself
doing things differently feeling things
differently it's not just food like
you're not just more sensitive to food
you're more sensitive to your own habits
it's uh kind of trippy
um yeah yeah I haven't done that type of
fast before I used to do intermittent
fasting just for the the Long Haul where
you basically only have like an eight
hour window of eating and so I was doing
that and I seemed to help out but um
yeah I don't know if I could do a whole
week without eating like what did you do
to supplement
you know like for like nutrition and
stuff like I know you said you drank a
lot of water like did you just water
or anything like that no no no calories
at all and um like I said I was doing I
was just you know scouring the internet
because it's basically the most ancient
medicine right like your body naturally
knows how to draw off its own Supply
because it burns like the glucose
like it's used to burning like
carbs first and then when it doesn't
have carbs to burn it'll move on to the
next source
and uh yeah your body goes into a state
of ketosis where it's basically running
off its own fat and it's burning off its
fat and you do store like toxins in your
fat so it was pretty gnarly like on day
three it felt like I came down with flu
like I felt like I was sick
um but it's like my body was just
detoxing on day five I felt amazing
actually like I'm talking five days of
not eating like I felt so good I just
wanted to go outside and go for a walk I
was like so stoked to just talk to
strangers and everything it was just a
weird
weird space to be in
[Music]
um
that's crazy
we all have questions
go ahead your first good I was gonna say
does does uh was your day three where
you felt really sick on your
on your week-long fast did you feel the
same way on your three-day fast on your
last day day three all sick and stuff
now now the three-day fast was actually
quite
quite manageable the whole time actually
the only thing I messed up on is that I
ate a cracker to break my fast and your
body will forget how to process carbs
you have to be very very gentle with
your body when you come off of an
extended water fast like that just one
cracker it was like that scene from the
Casino Royale uh where he gets his drink
poison and he's like walking through the
casino and you like just like slams the
salt down in the bathroom it was like
that off of just like one tiny little
cracker um wow that's crazy dude
geez um all right you guys have
questions
apologies I was just going to say like
when you're doing your week fast did you
do any type of like physical activity at
all or did you pretty much just like lay
up for the entire week more or less I
laid down um like I said on day five I
did want to just like go outside and go
for a walk not like a power walk or
anything I was really really being easy
on my body but
um yeah it's definitely very very deep
healing your body will go through I
think
um I see Devon I know Devon you probably
would know maybe more than I would but
like your body goes in this thing called
autophagy where it kind of like eats its
own
like cells that aren't really up to par
uh it kind of like is a spring cleaning
for your body you're like defragging
your body so to speak so
yeah I don't know I highly recommend it
obviously I think you know
you probably should consult with a
medical professional I don't want to
give medical advice here on the stream
you know I did it personally uh and I I
like yeah exactly when Bush if you're I
mean whoever Mikel would most of you
guys want to do like I'm down for like a
like a three day thing I've done a
three-day juice cleanse before
and that was like maybe a good start to
let Clint to like the the fasting life
um
it's manageable it's not just water and
then maybe you go from there but like
you know I'd be down it's probably more
fun with friends
oh go ahead go ahead no no you're good I
just was saying I would do a three day
one I don't maybe just to start with and
then maybe try to slowly get into a week
but yeah
down for that yeah for for not eating
I'm a bit reluctant because I'm already
too skinny for my height I think like I
don't know I don't remember the word but
it's like uh numbers you give your
height and your weight and it's like oh
you're too skinny or whatever okay yeah
yeah
index yeah right right so I probably
just wanna I gain weight and do you know
exercise but I do want to do a
technology
technology last week or something when
whenever I have a break that'd be pretty
cool and I I've heard this in a lot of
places it's like you always think you're
missing so many things like in reality
if one day I don't check my phone okay
I'll have a ton of notifications and
maybe like two friends have messages me
about something important at most but
it's not like you're actually missing
many things you know so
I don't know that last time my phone
broke I I waited a week before buying
the next one just to see and it was like
pretty chill so I might do that um
but when I get a break of course
yeah that sounds that sounds super nice
I'd be down for that
um
yeah go ahead
oh I just want to say I know when we did
camera graph that was pretty much like a
technology
um fast away from everything more
because well I didn't go this year but
the previous year on Portland we
literally got like no firm reception or
anything out there so you're kind of
forced to be off of your stuff and it's
the best I remember like every artist
pretty much coming back feeling
rejuvenized because it's just like you
took that four or five days away from
all technology and now you're like
feeling more creative and just ready to
go so I think maybe a technology detox
is something that more people should do
because we're just so enamored but even
if you're not on your computer you're
always on your phone so you always have
some type of like screen shooting pixels
at your eyes which probably can't be
good for your brain nah it's not natural
I mean certainly not yeah
I mean it is good but not as much I feel
like like there's a lot of good things
to get out of especially computers for
me the problem is more my phone than my
computer but yeah
yeah oh I was I was talking specifically
for like the pixels to the eyeballs but
um yeah I I uh I think that would be
that would be sweet and building in more
of those things next year for me I think
is a good a good positive thing that I
should
definitely be doing
um
I should say document it for your
channel maybe that could be
something that you like put up there one
week just like your detox that you went
through and how you're feeling each day
and you know that type of stuff that's
very interesting I've I've never
considered that but
you know maybe I was watching a bunch of
those videos during my week fast as
though people yeah so documenting their
detoxes documenting like yeah technology
detoxes their food detoxes so
can you document a technology detox
like can you do that like can you do
that
are you just filming in a film camera
yeah so you take it back to analog uh
maybe a clumsy choice of words there but
yeah they're like just they came back
and just like shared their experience
oh that's legit that's fun to me I love
that like I I don't just love 3D
challenges I love physical challenges
mental challenges like I did this thing
one time where I didn't talk for a
weekend but like I still went out to
like order food and like I went to the
spa too and I like you know just live
life normally and it was crazy it was it
was so cool like because I was living
with um my roommate Cliff Casey and Ally
and like you know we would be goofing
off 24 7 just like inside jokes
like Speedy inside jokes all the time
and to the point where it was like what
are we even saying anymore like what
what are we doing and um I don't think
that's why I took it
um or or did like the the silence for
the whole the whole weekend but
when I was doing it I remember like
being in the car with all of them and
like you know it was just jokes jokes
jokes jokes jokes jokes and I was like
it feels good not to to have to feel
socially obviated to contribute like wow
this is nice I love that and um
I realized
that
80 of what because I'd get I'd be like I
want to say this and I'd be like oh I
don't have to say it and I'd be like
what was the point of even saying that
what would that have brought to the
conversation like absolutely nothing
dang okay
so how much of what I say brings nothing
to the table and I was like huh that's
crazy
um it was so funny too like I went I
went to like uh to the spa this place
called we spa and um
I was just pointing I was just pointing
like I had questions I was writing
things down and I was like asking them
without asking them and the guy was like
and he wasn't talking either and and I
was like what
he was doing the same challenge he was
doing well no no he was just confused so
then like the the other like attendant
next to him behind the counter was like
you can talk he's just not talking you
can talk and he was like oh
that's so funny
I love that
because I was nervous I was like people
are gonna think I'm like weird people
are gonna think like
is he making fun of people who like
can't talk and I'm like well how would
they even know first off they wouldn't
know I was gonna say there are there are
mute people out there so yeah
um it's like everyone's everyone's weird
in La anyway so I'm like this is fine
um
but yeah it was it was cool it was very
very peaceful weekend and uh I could
imagine a phone detox or
some sort of
fast would be similar so I'm down like
when was she and I should try the num
talking thing that sounds like fun yeah
I should do that next weekend or
something it's fun it's crazy it's like
you'll
yeah it's like something you would never
do and it's like all right let's do it
it's pretty sweet those challenges are
so much fun uh I've done it not not for
two days straight but I've done like you
know like one day in school I did it
um but the teacher got mad at me so I
ended up having to talk uh but I will
I have a friend that does lemon eating
speed runs for example no no lemon
eating sweet Rhymes oh you'll take a
lemon like sit with the legs crust and
then he starts eating he opens the lemon
with his hands also no tools no nothing
super weird slurping noises and then
when he's done he touches his legs and
that's the time so then he goes into the
editing and like checks frame perfect
has a spreadsheet with his stems so much
it's a lot of citrus yeah dude you gotta
balance that out
that's great I love people like that
that's yeah that's the best
um
freaking good times what do you guys
want to do what do you guys want to talk
about we're chilling um we were gonna go
till
two o'clock so I mean that's two hours
from now we don't have to go all the way
till two but you know we're we're
chilling what are you guys feeling what
do you guys want to get into
I wanted to bring this up because I just
got this at Five Below this crazy thing
yeah what is this what is this I don't
know do you guys have you probably have
Five Below Clint do you have five below
Adam and Mikhail it's almost like what
is that dollar store but everything is
like five dollars right so I was in
there getting batteries and I saw this I
wish I had the box with me because it
had like legit pictures of like Zelda
and Mario or Lincoln Mario on the cover
and it's like 500 games for like five
dollars so I got it just out of
curiosity because I'm like there's no
way they legally put you know like Mario
Brothers and excite bike and all that
stuff on there but if I turn it on I
don't know if you guys can see it but it
was like Double Dragon excite bike final
fight like it has like legit games on
here I'm like how the heck are they not
getting sued like this is crazy like
this is
right right there I'm just like
does it have an audio like a like a
headphone jack
yeah there's a headphone jack at the top
um it has um it can't make a positive
cables too if you want to hook it up to
a TV
but literally if I hit like there's
Ninja Turtles right here
oh this is the Japanese version Let me
see because like a game that I put on
literally had like the Nintendo Lego pop
up at the front
so yeah it has like Capcom games and
tatio
what is it called
um let me see it says Tech Solutions
made in China that's like all this is on
there but Tech Solutions
Tech Solutions the gaming box yeah I
just I picked it up because I'm like
this is crazy there's no waiters legit
ROMs on here and I'm like how how is
this franchise not getting sued like
they sold it at like a actual store
brick and mortar store you could walk
into like it's pretty crazy
dang this feels like a frankincense
type of thing I don't know if you guys
if you guys are in Southern California
Frank and Sons is like mini Comic Con
it's like Comic-Con
for the like it's like DIY Comic Con
three times a week right it's the best
dude this is crazy is that in Pasadena
no no it's in City of Industry it's the
best thing ever like they've been around
for so long I went with my dad as a kid
and like it's still here it's even
better now like they upped it to the Max
and there's like vendors everywhere you
can get
or like they had a Crash Bandicoot vinyl
on sale I was like what that's so crazy
so it's like a swap meet right it is for
but like for nerdy stuff and like magic
cards Pokemon cards game boys uh like
figurines and like Collectibles all that
stuff
but nothing there's license like it's
just all
like people just going in and doing
their own thing yeah it's all vendors
like it's just yeah you could go in
there you could rent out a little booth
and then you could just fill it with
whatever you want
that's pretty wild yeah it's super cool
um but uh what what are you guys trying
to get into next to your hobby wise
because I know like I I really want to
get into more music stuff like I picked
up one of these guys one of these little
pocket operators and it's like a little
sequencer and stuff and oh I've seen you
posted something for Christmas I think
yeah I heard on my Christmas list yeah
the Space Fighter and the Mega Man one
yes dude they're so freaking cool and so
powerful
um
so I've been I've been into that like I
want to make some beats I want to make
some ambient music I've been hitting up
Adam like you've been showing me like uh
Ableton a little bit it's pretty
overwhelming but it's fun it's exciting
but what about you guys what are you
guys trying to get into this year for
next year we might have to do a Discord
with Adam because you know this year I
was trying to get into music I got the
MPC I got the um a cab midi keyboard and
um yeah I was trying to get into music I
was making some stuff but don't 100
understand Ableton like I have Ableton
like because it came with a lot of
hardware and stuff like that but I think
I've been kind of just brute forcing
that you know like making the the chords
on the NPC bring it into Ableton and
then just kind of chopping everything up
and trying to arrange the music there
but you know just having fun with it not
really doing it on a professional level
that I don't think because it just seems
like my message is kind of all over the
place but
we definitely love to see like the
correct way of doing it no man there's
no correct way no no one's no one's
seeing the music dude
they're hearing it exactly yeah well
every time I'm in there I'm like there
has to be a better way to do all this
stuff like I'm I'm literally like brute
forcing it but it it works you know
yeah it's fun like I I was doing a lot
of research on music and uh technology
like the different gear and stuff and I
had no idea
like I don't know I don't know anything
I'm just youtubing stuff and um
been following this guy Ricky Tina's and
he's awesome oh my god dude that guy is
so freaking awesome his videos are so
well shot hit so well lit he's super
chill he's so good at explaining the
technology and he's been walking me
through these pocket operators and like
the stuff he puts out with these things
are crazy
um it's so much fun and like I don't
know if it was him or another guy but
they were talking about like
the difference between
having your music set up at a computer
big old setup versus like tiny portable
stuff like this and they were saying
like the differences
you know you're coming you're coming to
your your studio to make music to
produce the coolest track possible and
to have the world hear it like Adam this
is what you know this is what you've
kind of built your career on right is
making music that people can turn on in
their car on their on their stereo
system whatever
it's mixed well it sounds great it's a
full song Right versus a like a jam
where it's just like a live kind of a
thing and it's more for just like I
guess similar similar to journaling it's
not no one's really recording it or
filming it
um and it's just there to be a fun thing
in that very moment and like
I don't know I've always liked that
about jamming that
just in that moment it sounds so cool
and maybe when you listen back to the
recording it's it doesn't sound good but
at least in that moment it's fun
um exactly
yeah yeah it's like that IG video you
sent me that guy when he made music when
he's hiding he went back and listened to
it and just like yeah
yeah that's so funny dude I was dying
that's too good oh we got Christian in
the chat what's up Christian Corridor
Christian up in here chilling
hey what up good to see you dude
um
I don't know what is it funny how that
I say it's kind of funny how that always
um like our two industries always kind
of cross-pollinate because it's like I
know a lot of 3D artists that are always
like I'm buying an instrument whether
it's a guitar or like you synth or
whatever and I've learned how to make
music this year and then a lot of audio
buddies that I have they're always like
I want to learn after effects or I want
to learn you know blender or whatever so
it's kind of funny like how people are
like Professionals in their craft but
they always want to jump over to the
other side like it's always kind of
interesting how creative is kind of work
in that sense
to me they always made a lot of sense
it's like you're either too visual
like moving art or you know like because
if you draw that's like doing one note
in my mind obviously it's not but what I
mean is like you time like pacing for
example really translates from video to
music I would guess I I'm really bad at
music I wouldn't know but I don't know
it always felt natural to me oh that
happens
yeah I think it's like a a thing where I
I don't know I think we're all similar
we all got a lot of hobbies
um and I try to
I always feel like I have to be doing
something
whether that's good or bad but uh I
can't really be do like I can't really
do video stuff in my free hobby time
like Adam like we were saying like you
can't do music after music because
you know kind of done you've been doing
a lot of music so what Adam what's the
thing for you that's that like free time
hobby that you're just like the world
doesn't need to see it this one's for
you and you get happiness out of it
oh dude riding my bike
like your bicycle
that's right
what kind do you have uh
uh it's uh I guess it's a street bike
because there's no shocks on it
is that what yeah yeah like I gotta well
I guess it's been a few years now I got
a Saunders bike electric bike when they
first came out and that kind of got me
back in the biking again
is that like a pedal assist or is it got
a throttle on it it has a throttle but
it's more pedal assist like if you're
throttling the whole time you're gonna
get like 25 30 minutes out of it but
okay if you use it for a pedal assist
you could get pretty far with it
that's pretty rad yeah and here in
Portland there's a lot of people
um that are just like zooming on their
e-bikes it's like cyborgs like you're
you're on your bike and you'll see
someone like paddling at a quarter of
the rate you are and they're just like
you're like right
cyborgs freaking Advanced humans like it
just it has this like whirring sound
like the bike you can hear it's like
[Music]
yeah crazy case I I had this uh long
board I actually have it here I brought
it to the new city but I I've never had
a chance to ride it here and my dad was
like okay I'll buy you like if you want
that bike or a longboard or skates I
don't care if I have another electric
because you need to do Sports and that's
just like a monster Mike and I'm like
okay uh Alan gortris very nicely paid
for it like a pedal like a
yeah yeah but like I mean you gotta like
kick you have to power it with your legs
look kind of longboard because every
time
yes I don't know if you've seen the
electric longboard
this is the one I have it's just a
normal on board
oh I like those colors that's nice yeah
it's nice it's pretty good
um but there's these ones that have like
a thick battery here and they have like
a Bluetooth remote and yeah it's crazy
it's crazy and it's so funny yeah those
things are nuts I I definitely prefer
the one wheel you turn on a dime but
that's that's just me of course I I'm
biased um Adam what do you get out of
the bike man like what what does it do
for you why is it important
oh oh I wanted to ask real quick and in
Los Angeles are you seeing the one
Wheels where like your feet are on the
left and the right of the wheel and
you're going full
yes these guys are just like
yeah exactly yeah I was I was at a food
cart and this dude rolls up in like full
like body armor so I was like I was
gonna chat with him about motorcycles I
was like oh dude what do you ride he's
like a one wheel and I was like whoa but
yeah they're like they're on I was like
how fast are you going that you need to
gear up that hard dude and it's exactly
it dude those guys are like zooming like
on one of the bridges here in the city
which is basically an extension freeway
like there's just a dude keeping up with
traffic I was like how are you gonna
stop like you have to put all your
points of evasion of something bad
happen because you're not gonna break
dude right those things like sketch man
like face plant and you're done
so are they riding on the street with
the vehicles or are they riding on the
side yes dude they're riding with the
cars I've seen it a couple times yeah
they go super fast like you can just
Cruise it and you like look over to your
left or it was a dude just like slanted
45 degrees forward just like looking and
he's like what's up you're just like
crazy
by the way my friend sent me the eating
lemon video do you guys want to check it
out
oh no I want to watch someone eat a
lemon
yeah let's do it okay let me figure out
how to do this who's this friend what is
this what is his name
you've heard of him yeah visual
no are we talking visual right now or no
okay no he's another one of them okay
okay
let me try to figure out this screen
sure uh
are you sure
okay soda while you're doing that Adam
tell me about the bike what's the bike
gets you that no we got the lemons all
right
here we go okay
transition and then I bring this up
okay okay okay I got it
so this is a video
this is already creepy
is doing it like without tools which is
very impressive already
so
is this like a comp like is this a sport
yeah is this like a bear is this just
this guy
I think it's just him that's a thing I
don't know I think it's just him this
was a pretty good speedrunner but no
lemon speedrunning Community or
something like this yeah I would have to
there has to be one this is like people
slash lemon speedrun
no peel and there he swallowed when he
does that I mean especially when he
throws his hands up I mean I feel like
that that's a competition thing it's
like a legit thing with graphs and stuff
I don't know what the dude I bet okay
this is Dad all right imagine his dad
cantaloupe speedruns all right he was
like the master of cantaloupe speedruns
and then
like that was like he knew his dad doing
that as a child but then his dad was
like you know what I was world champion
for too long I'm retiring and he's like
son I think I think you're gonna like
this
so he gets them started on small stuff
like grapes
grape speed runs I don't know if you
guys know I I think this isn't
everywhere but in Spain when the New
Year happens like we eat 12 grapes on
the 12th is the new year is that only a
Spain thing definitely yeah I never
heard of that I've never heard of that
it's like a whole thing in TV they have
like a Pac-Man thing in the bottom of
the screen and you're supposed to eat at
the same time people peel the grapes
sometimes if they're oh I don't know uh
but yeah it's quite fine so for a moment
in time you're eating a grape with
a bunch of other people say the entire
country that's powerful yeah
that's a Vibe yeah that's pretty cool
so you're an odd person not if you're
that one person not eating the grape at
that particular time yeah
yeah I mean some people eat other stuff
like M Ms or something but oh we'll talk
about that I like grapes grapes are good
yeah we don't talk about them are we
talking green grapes or purple grapes is
there like a is usually green of it but
usually green yeah dude those cotton
candy grapes though
yeah my wife and I love this
they're so good like if you crush a
whole bag though I'm pretty sure that's
not healthy that's got to be like 60
grams of sugar or something like that 70
grams probably even more my daughter's
done it plenty of times oh I've done it
too yeah yeah
crazy I remember I was I was I was
checking out at the grocery store and I
had a bag of those cotton candy grapes
and like it's always a thing with me
when I buy them to like ask the the
clerk if they've ever tried them because
I want to like be the person that
Witnesses them trying it for the first
time because I remember when I tried one
for the first time I was like it tastes
like cotton candy how do they do that
you know and I remember one time this
one lady she takes a bite and she just
like puckers up and like goes like this
and I was like whoa is it a sour patch
and she's like you like these and I was
like yeah just like they taste like
cotton candy and I was like I know
I thought it was just the name like a
name of a variety but I didn't expect it
to like taste like that
what's the nastiest thing y'all have
ever eaten in your entire life
um
so when I went to school I ate lunch
there for like years
and because of allergies I I couldn't
eat egg or nuts but they were like also
you can't eat fish for no reason I'm
like but I like fish they're like nope
so they gave me like this nasty meat
I was convinced it was like a piece of
of lungs or something lungs is that like
the breathing organ yeah yeah yeah okay
I was right
um and it was like you would put the
fork in and it was like deep it was like
it was nasty it was oh and I I would
almost throw up every time the guy there
would make me eat it I was like just
take a tiny bite Ellie did he was like
no
the worst thing ever
anyway
yeah I can't say I mean I keep my my
food is pretty simple so yeah nothing
too crazy I don't get adventurous when
it comes to food
oh yeah like when you travel uh
um
no matter what but
you said you eat chicken tenders no I'm
asking if you're the chicken tenders no
matter what dude
um probably the cheeseburger but yeah
the cheeseburger no matter what dude yep
yep but um can't go wrong yeah I mean I
I might try some local stuff but I can't
say anything's been terrible you know
it's just not my a thing though
yeah
Adam do you have any any horror stories
I mean dude I made like a bunch of fail
meals you know that of in private but I
can't remember the recipe for
the failure of it
um
no I don't got anything uh that's a bad
question guys it's cool it's cool it's a
bad question no no like the intention
behind the question was so good though
you felt the intention
okay I'm trying to go story time I'm
trying I'm trying to steer it into like
some story time oh you got one
yeah yeah
what
do you have a bad food or meal you have
no not really
I mean I've had like I I saw when I was
in China I saw a freaking
like a like you know five gallon little
like like uh freaking I don't know what
do you call it the little water jug you
get water from it uh cooler like a water
cooler thing and uh there was like
snakes in it with like
I could say some of the nastiest stuff
I've seen I've been to those markets
over in China before and they have some
pretty gnarly stuff there like it it is
pretty crazy
yeah um like I've had chicken feet
before and like
I don't like them it's just peeling skin
off of like soggy skin off a bone
but maybe there's like the place for
chicken even like is there any meat on
chicken feet like what are you eating
exactly
I don't know in my experience like I've
I've rarely eaten it but like I grew up
with my buddy Marcus and um he's Chinese
so his parents we would go to dim sum
like all the time all the time we go to
dim sum it was the best like some of the
best memories of my childhood and um
like they would have chicken feet there
and I'd be like yeah let's go I'll try
some chicken feet it was never my
favorite but
yeah I don't know
it wasn't there like uh I'm probably
misremembering but it wasn't there a
story where you ate a silk or something
I'm pretty wrong something with that saw
no that was Jimmy I
that's two stores I don't know when you
say nasty sock story two things come to
mind first
it was when we were living in uh on
Hunter Street in suite number six where
uh the stress level zero offices now
this is when Freddie and Brandon were
doing their thing
um on on Hunter Street still
and uh
I remember this okay so the previous
night me and Brett were roommates the
previous night I scared Brett so bad and
I like who knows if this is why but he
woke up the next day with Batman Nick
like he couldn't move you know what I'm
saying he just tweaked something in his
neck
and he was out for the day and I was
like son let me have Nick yeah I was
like son I'm gonna help you out here
so I was like hurry hurry like let's
find something I think Max was there my
old roommate Max
and uh
he was like quick
we gotta heat something up and and like
and put it on his neck and I was like
okay
so I don't know why I was thinking like
I gotta make a DIY
like hot pad for his neck so I saw
an old
tortilla
and then I saw a sock in the corner and
I was like
I'ma put these two things together heat
them up in the microwave and then put it
on his neck and he'll be all better and
dude it smelled so bad and I put it on
his neck
that's definitely sorry I thought I
remembered yeah yeah oh yeah
um that was rough the other the other
sock story
me and Jimmy we would play Mario Kart
all the time and we would like we would
play so much
that we would start betting each other
like challenges that if we got first or
second we had to do something and I bet
I'm like if I get if whoever gets first
second place has to lick the other
person's foot and it was like
you know I I was gonna have him Blake my
Barefoot that's gross
um
we had our socks on of course so he goes
to lick my sock because of course I won
I always get first place and um
that was a that was a pretty gold moment
for in my life I don't know
those are my those are my sock stories
so you're speaking of Mario Kart the new
tracks just came out today what are you
serious
yeah yeah the moon cup and uh rocket cup
they're probably gonna play that tonight
on game night dude I might have said
that
come on I should get more into video
games I I barely play I I started
playing a little bit of OverWatch with
friends now
um I I bought a switch when it came out
and everything uh but now a friend has
it uh he was actually my teacher uh but
now he's he's a friend
um yeah I should get it back and just
start playing video games again
it's a good
um
yeah I know like earlier we were talking
about like stuff do like away from your
work to kind of just like dig um
decompress and I know for me video games
is a big part of that especially like
Story video games like I just played
through a plagues to Requiem and yeah it
was so good like I know a lot of people
are talking about God of War this year
but I would say Blake's tale was
probably up there for probably one of
the best stories and this kind of
playing through those interactive story
games and stuff like that it's pretty um
it's pretty relaxing you know like I
enjoy doing that type of stuff
I mean I was so close to playing that
game I had the The Game Pass and like I
downloaded that game and I just didn't
play it but it just looks sick oh man
it's so that's exactly where I played it
on Game Pass it's it's good like have
you played the first one
no yeah you yeah you definitely want to
play the first one first because they
kind of go back to back but they're both
really good
I saw it at um
game awards a couple nights ago it won
something didn't it that story or is
nominated for best story or something
yeah I know it was nominated for a bunch
of stuff but um I didn't watch the full
game award so I didn't get to see what
it won but yeah what surprised me I mean
the story is pretty good basically for
anybody that didn't play it it's about
the um about the black plague that
happened you know centuries back in I
guess it would say I'm not sure what
country they're in somewhere in Europe
but um this kid has the ability to
basically control the rats that spread
the plague around I don't want to give
away the story but it's it's pretty
gnarly the whole entire thing is pretty
dope
that's awesome oh dang I'm looking at
the trailer now they're like swarming
rats that's crazy
yeah through the stream that sounds like
fun
yeah I know it came out last the first
one came out when I say 2019 on like the
Xbox one and PlayStation 4. but with the
currents doing in the new technology
there's just like a multiple two there's
more rats that are on the screen at any
given time like it's just crazy just
seeing those big Swarms Out There it's
so funny that more rats is a selling
point for them
I mean it really is I mean it gets
overwhelming like you get fairly plus
the audio design like the music and
audio design and voice acting is really
good like it all came together really
well
heck yeah I um you know I've been
hearing all all the the hype for uh
shoot what's that game with the
Dinosaurs uh what's Ashley Birch
oh the um with the robot dinosaurs yes
um horizon horizon yeah zero Dawn yeah
yeah so I don't know
yeah so those games like
I I missed out on that one and I'm like
oh I want to get into this and I
downloaded it and I think I I got maybe
a few hours in and it was like too big
for me for some reason like
it it was overwhelming too much stuff to
do I get overwhelmed with those like
open world type games and I had just
finished like ghost of tsushima and I I
got to a level 100 in Elgin ring and
still didn't beat that so I'm like I
don't think I'm ready for this which is
why astray
dude I beat that game today oh my God
yeah that was good
Got Game of the Year best uh indie game
of the year
which is deserved it oh 100 it was
nominated for a game of the year too
which is crazy
um but that game that game's awesome
Adam you're playing that right now
aren't you
yeah I I I I dropped it
um
I don't know why I just got occupied
with other things but yeah I love I love
the sound design of that game so much
and I love all the just like
miscellaneous cat functions they can
they give you yeah that like don't serve
any purpose other than being like yeah
you're playing as a cat
yeah those kind of drove me crazy at
first because I'm like especially you
know like you you gotta interact with
something then I'm sitting there and I'm
like is something supposed to happen
it's like no he's just chilling he's
just laying down this camera like slowly
pins back just general cat activities is
what you're getting into with that
prompt
yeah did you did you beat it when Bush
oh yeah we my daughter and I bend
straight through that I think probably
like two or three places
heck yeah yeah it's yeah it's freaking
so good
I think I was starting with a guy
um
there's this guy he's pretty much like a
Unreal Engine God like he used to make
this crazy stuff on YouTube and Unreal
Engine 4. and he kind of disappeared I
was telling clintus yesterday
um I think his name was like Kula okay
or something like that I sent you his
YouTube channel but yeah he was making
amazing stuff in unreal like people
couldn't even add them like how he was
making it then he kind of just
disappeared it wasn't putting content up
anymore and then out of nowhere like the
trailer drops for stray and it's him
like he created this game found well he
started it by himself and then he got
funding I think through like Sony or
something for it it was able to finish
it out but it's kind of crazy to see
like one person be able to create
something on that magnitude like by
themselves like we have the type of
Technology now to where anybody could
kind of create anything that your mind
could think of like it's pretty well
dude this is this is like the highest
level thing I remember I've seen this
this like storm test I dropped a link in
the in the chat for you guys to look at
and I remember seeing this being like
holy crap this looks so good and to find
out that's the same guy who did stray
makes me so happy
yeah
it makes sense like the environments
that are in straight like you get once
you realize it's the same guys like okay
now it makes sense by those those
environments look so good
that's
the kind of stuff that gives me super
amped to to do 3D and like make
environments in Worlds and stuff it's
like
these super nice use cases are man
they're so inspiring
I mean he did like an earthquake
simulator that looked pretty good on his
channel like there's a lot of good stuff
that he was pumping out there and
I'm kind of happy to see that his game
got so much recognition because I I like
I don't know because I don't know him
personally but I feel like it's straight
too is probably
coming at some point you know oh dude
I'm ready for it that game was too good
the music
yeah freaking incredible
I think he just came up with the whole
idea by just interacting with his cat
like that's stuff like he's real cat and
everything
it's awesome
yeah so yeah you can tell he had a cat
like each other yeah
man too many things to do not enough
time
yes so he's speaking at a game awards I
know you guys saw the the Orthodox Rabbi
Bill Clinton getting shot I love it dude
that guy is
oh man just uh incredible dude like
absolute
Flex just I was sneaking sneaking up on
stage
I saw it live and I was like what who's
this janky looking dude in the
background he does not look like he
belongs
with these with these guys I'm like what
is going on
I wish I watched it all the way through
now to witness that live because I saw
pit like I didn't get to watch the full
thing and then I saw people talking
about it the next day and I'm like what
like what's this meme of this kid you
know just chilling there did not watch
the actual clip and I was just like holy
crap this is his goal like just seeing
him walk up the other owl you know as
they yeah the winner like he's a part of
the team he's like this nope
I'm so lost
all right but you have to check it out
this kid at the um game awards so Elden
Ring the video game one like game of the
year so you know the Elder ring team
went to go up on stage to get the trophy
and do their Acceptance Speech but this
other kid randomly got out of his seat
and walked up with them up on stage as
if he was a part of that team and so you
know he let the team give their speeches
and you know their congratulations and
everything and then at the very end he's
just like okay now it's my turn to speak
and he's like I'd like to nominate my
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton for
something and everybody's just like what
the like it's such a weird awkward
moment but yeah it's great
yeah I think this is a link to it
drop it in the chat
yeah it was weird I was like what did he
just say what was that and I like texted
my friends who are also watching it
and like they barely caught it I was
like am I the only one who saw this what
is going on here
is um
um my boyfriend James try pixels he's in
the chat he was saying that um I guess
that's what my kids I guess that's what
he's done for he's like some kid from
like 4chan or something and he pops up
in random places giving like shots out
to Bill Clinton but that's probably like
the biggest skill one that he got to do
freaking lost it dude
like yeah there's
for me it wasn't even uh him getting on
the mic it was just the awkwardness of
him in the background but you could tell
like he didn't belong there and he
looked nervous as heck just like
standing there and the cameras were like
on him and everything too like no one
questioned the entire time he was up
there
it's like when when I was watching it
and you had like the main shot on the
main guy from Elden ring and uh
in the background I was like that guy is
like he's not standing with the team
he's standing behind everybody and I'm
like that that's weird and he he looked
like a kid like who's this random like
kid
and sure enough
yeah
ourselves are always like so messy
lately with with the Oscars and the
whole uh Will Smith thing and then like
even before I don't know if you guys
remember the clip of the Oscars he's the
camera guy being like this on the actors
like when they're getting nominated no
and then
I gotta find them like trying to ignore
the camera you know they're like smiling
imagine the camera is like super close
like like this and they're just like
looking at the screen clapping and then
the camera guy is ah I don't know it was
really awkward weird
yeah I feel like back into it they're
gonna be doing like the game awards and
you have to like register all the people
they're gonna go up with you now so that
doesn't happen again but it
I mean it's like it's it's tough because
you know like it's a creative Community
right so it's not like the Oscars where
everybody has like you know like gowns
and tuxedos on and everybody looks like
they should be there like the game
awards everybody's wearing all types of
random stuff so it's like
he used to stop that kid like you don't
look like you belong in this group
because I mean he looked like any other
you know game artists out there so it
would be kind of hard to say like oh
this kid doesn't fit in with that Vibe
because I mean he that could just be you
know like the type of stuff that he
wears or you know just the vibe he puts
off yeah oh yeah 100 I don't think there
was there was any way to stop that
unless it's like a future thing it's
like who's going up on stage with you
clear them and then now you know anyone
else not on this list doesn't get to go
but
yeah that was that was pretty hilarious
the only thing that put it through a red
flag was he came from the whole opposite
side of the stadium there and not like
sitting with the team so I mean that
should have threw some Flags off
definitely
I found the clip of the actors being
super close up let me try to show it
don't don't get us demonized here
that should be fine
okay
keep it like this it's just I don't know
I'll make it big but it's really really
awkward they're like super close
and the camera guy just keeps
like being there
or like
it's just so awkward
so does he zoomed in or is he like
really like up on everybody
no he's like close because you can see
the like focal length and everything
yeah they look uncomfortable too
yeah and these are the people that are
like best at not looking uncomfortable
on camera it's crazy anyway I just think
it's a funny clip he's like right in
between their kneecaps what yeah
too funny hey
cringy
how you guys feeling
good good
you try you want to try and pop off one
of these Discord games Adam do you have
a setup
you have a computer setup uh screen
share situation
I do
I mean we're chilling status
status
[Music]
so I think for the Discord game we would
have to be like in your Discord though
I think
oh all right yes that's complicated
yeah we'd have to
re-regon like your actual actual
physical Discord
it's cool
we can probably maybe we can do some uh
Karthik phone or something
yeah
do you ever play anything with your
audience or anything online like where
you have other people participate just
in the chat
I mean that'd be interesting I don't
know what options would there be for
that I guess we could do garchick phone
and
maybe have some people hop in
um
people got some questions too with
people yeah maybe it's some questions
it's good yeah let's let's go to you
guys let's go to the chat here see if
you have if you guys have any questions
um I know Edge you got a question hit us
with an at hit me with at Punisher so I
can see it in the chat here
um and then even if it's for a Winbush
or for Adam that way we can just kind of
like
you know get a better visual on all the
questions so I'll start with edge here
um how do you manage what you do in the
short term based on the long-term goals
oh shoot yeah I had a problem with that
this year like I was saying earlier like
I feel like the schedule the posting
schedule on this channel is so packed
even though it's twice a week sorry oh
God twice a month
um I'm just laying one train track at a
time and I've kind of lost sight of the
long-term goals this year because of
that and I'm not I'm not chill with that
so that's definitely one of the things
that I want to work on next year is
having a bit more foresight in the year
um and not being as crunched like
how I'm gonna do that I think
it's either taking on less or
getting help hiring help like I I might
try and hire an editor or maybe hire
someone to help me with thumbnails or
hire someone for social media or all
three you know at once uh I don't know
but I definitely need to like start
getting more help because it's too
difficult to do on my own with all the
stuff that I want to do you know all
that stuff like minus making a movie
geez but it's tough when your YouTube
channel is like full time uh we're gonna
sing one bush
and I said you're you're working on a
film still oh yeah man it's it's always
like it's the whole reason I
picked up a camera 16 years ago in the
first place so
um
yeah man absolutely just the YouTube
channel takes up all of my time I have
no time outside of that and I have to
start
you know building
barriers I can't just wake up and work
on the channel I have to split things up
I got to be smart about it so yeah Edge
I'm working on that um what about you
guys do you have any like way to manage
the short term
stuff you're working on and have it
reach the longer term stuff
um I mean my my biggest long-term goal
right now is like I wanted to hit a
hundred thousand on my YouTube channel
more because I wanted that YouTube
plaque you know the silver button plaque
so that was probably my long term so to
hit that in the short term you know I've
just been you know pumping out the
educational content week after week but
um yeah I would say like we were
alluding to you know just mental being
and physical being like my long-term
goal is just to be as healthy as
possible so just trying to have the
small victories you know like I'm going
to try the fasting thing with you guys
and just try to take it one step at a
time because I know my experience
whenever you try to do any type of like
Quick Fix like crash dieting or you know
with it whatever the latest trend is
that it never works out like you always
gotta just take it kind of slow and easy
if you want to do this for a long haul
so yeah that's that's it for me there
yeah for sure
um in my case I'm pretty lucky like they
line up pretty well they're short on the
long term I just want to work in movies
uh their VFX or animation I like both so
I'll decide when the time comes and in
the short term I'm just doing school
work and freelance so like I'm pretty
lucky with that for now we'll see in the
future though
Adam
I mean I can relate like I
to what you're saying about
stuff in the short term kind of taking
up all your time so I don't know I'm
trying to improve on that as well
because these songs working on for my
album I feel like should have been done
years ago to be honest so I've
successfully
been busy with short-term stuff for a
long term time so yeah something I'm
going to be working on next year
yeah I feel it's like a priority thing
you know it's what's important and then
put your time towards that and it's
definitely easier said than done
unfortunately but
yeah I always say not enough hours in a
day but I'm always like if there was
more hours in the day I would probably
still say that you know exactly dude one
of those things you know
because we do say like oh there's not
enough time in the week month that's why
it's kind of hard
um let's see that was a good question
Edge thank you uh let's see what else we
got here
[Music]
um
oh
uh let's see okay so
when 58 says
I don't know
I don't know if you answer this but how
do you deal with procrastinating from
your projects until the last minute
deadline also wind should be a good time
to hire people for YouTube
um yeah procrastination I so I I've
learned that like
for me
um
pretty sure I got ADHD
and I think my mom we all do has it too
yeah yeah yeah
um so I'm kind of scattered man I'm
coming all over the place
procrastinating well starting something
is always the hardest and uh
um I've learned that like
you using that last minute
as a push to do the work is what I need
which is kind of jacked
uh in the same way yeah
yep 100
yeah yeah same same really
that's how I got through my last album
was just like insane procrastination
energy
dang clean I'm sure you remember because
it was literally yesterday I was like oh
yeah we'll set up the stream after I
finish the essay I have because I need
to finish it at 12 today and I've been
procrastinating all week so yeah yep but
I mean at least the deadline kind of
works you know like I we get stuff done
obviously but at the same time I feel
like it'd be so much less stressful if
you could just force yourself to do it
because
at least for me it's always in the back
of my mind you know like I need to do it
I need to do it I might try doing it and
then I'm like less productive than if I
just didn't try because instead of doing
other stuff I could do
I'm just like trying forcing myself to
finish the thing so I don't know but
for me I felt like I felt like I'm more
focused when it comes down to like that
when you're at like that final hour
where it's like okay you have the
deadline you have to get it in and for
some reason that's when I become more
Lego focused like when something is just
kind of dangling out there and I don't
have a deadline or you know the
deadlines far down the line it's like
hard to stay laser focused for that
amount of time but once it's like oh
crap I got six hours to get this done
then it's like I'm laser focused on that
six hours because I know it has to get
completed yeah
also I try to leverage the kind of
motivation or the hype that you get at
the beginning of every project like you
know because if it's a cool project then
I'm like oh dude this is so cool then I
I use that as much as I can and then
when I get tired it's like harder you
keep working at it if it's a big project
and then when it's get it gets close to
that line you get like another boost
again so
that helps sometimes
I feel like a lot of artists are kind of
like that though I wonder if it's just
the way that like creatives are kind of
wired in the brain mm-hmm
yeah I I
want to find an easier way though
because for me it feels like
I'm in stop and go traffic to the max
where I I finish a project and I hit the
brakes hard and I sit there until I see
there's a giant Gap in front of me I'm
getting horns from the back and I'm like
oh I gotta go forward and I like
and then
blast off right and then and then as
soon as the project is done I slammed
the brakes and come to a screeching halt
and be like oh I gotta chill now I can't
like I can't I can't go I'm not going
and I think that's the burnout thing
like in Little doses
um
and I'm like I think my life is just
will always be a search for like a
smooth balanced
kind of workflow and I don't know if
I'll ever like
be balanced it's so easy for me to get
out of balance
um it's the hardest to be in balance and
it's just constant it feels like
constant work and it's hard when you're
burned out so it's
um yeah that's definitely something I'll
be working on next year gotta get that
figured out for sure
I don't know if anybody has it figured
out or perfected because I feel like
like I was saying like a lot of this
pretty much are in that same situation
so it just might be the type of thing
where
yeah that's just this is how we're built
okay I don't think anybody at least that
I know of
has it like perfected toward or just
like coasting the entire time it's
always like this chaotic organization to
it that just happens to work out you
know
yeah yeah yeah it's almost a good
problem to have in the sense that at
least we love what we do you know so I
feel like some people just don't find
that thing they love that they can also
make a living from and then they're just
like on a soft burnout for their entire
career kind of so I don't know
but it's like is there is there a house
you know yeah yeah there's gotta be
right like
yeah I mean that's what a discipline
comes in that right like you have to
discipline yourself to be able to do
that but that's tough
it is
um let's take another question here
um
okay all right I think this is a good
one that we can all we can all uh answer
here what would be the tool slash
software you're not using in your
workflow at the moment but we'll be
using um but would be using if you'd be
able to learn instantly basically what
what program or tool are you guys trying
to get into next year to you know make
your creative situation better this is
from Thomas
um
I don't know if it'll make it better but
I've been on and off trying to get in
the blender lately like still you know I
love Cinema 4D love everything on Max on
but it's just been hard to ignore
blender in our community you know like
they're doing a lot of crazy stuff over
there and every time I'm on you know
like Twitter Instagram I'm seeing all
types of like crazy creative stuff being
built for a blender in a community you
know like with the plugins and the
blender Marketplace like I literally saw
somebody make some type of geometry node
that allowed you to make like a river
and all you had to do is like click on
splines and kind of like make the shape
of your River like that's crazy I'm like
yeah that they're doing that type of
stuff all the time over in blender
community so I'm like I I have to tap in
because that's like no
that's just where my brain's at always
being creative and always doing crazy
stuff like I love that type of
innovation
yeah I feel it too it's like I want
those sweet updates too that's awesome
and now they're making a a solver inside
geometry notes kind of so you can
iterate through things basically it's
becoming like a small Houdini on that
side but then you have all the other
cool stuff that Houdini's in the best
that like you know
non-procedural modeling or or animation
or things like that I think it's really
powerful
um but I already know it so for me it's
Houdini and lately like last week I
started learning nuke uh for compositing
oh nice it's really I'm really enjoying
it's really really fun I already knew uh
Blackmagic Fusion so it's a really
smooth transition for me because I
already do composite nowadays this is
learning the new names of the notes and
couple hotkeys right yeah
um so Adam you're definitely on the
music side of things so do you want to
briefly kind of uh like describe the
software you use just real quick and
then just give the audience a sense of
kind of like what those things do for
people who don't use Music
um or don't produce music and then give
us an idea of like if there's something
that you're trying to get into next year
uh technique wise tool wise uh yeah what
do you think
I mean honestly I've been
procrastinating on learning unreal uh
just so that I could make my own visuals
to go with my music but yeah on the
music into things I just use
one piece of software called Ableton and
um yeah a bunch of
other like mini softwares that do very
specific jobs for audio
so that's uh that's basically it so
you're trying to learn are you still
trying to
oh go go ahead Mikhail yeah what's an
example of like a really specific like
what would it do for example
um you know like uh there's a program
called Paul stretch it's been around for
a long time I think it's a very I got
famous when you would like see Justin
Bieber videos or songs stretched out to
like 800 times or whatever and it would
sound like a beautiful Ambient Drone uh
so just like things like that that have
very specific functions or uh there's
this um there's this one thing I use
called send plant which is like you you
drop a seed in and you like grow a plant
and you like edit the DNA and it like
creates a sound as your uh as you're
like changing the the way the plant
grows and everything it's like really
creative synthesizer that's cool yeah
that's nice it's like a visual instead
of twisting knobs you're growing a plant
essentially
yeah but it's different than like you
guys in the 3D Community like I know
there's it's kind of like a symphony of
a bunch of different programs it can all
kind of come together and you can
composite it in one place
um
right
you know for me it's like microphones
and uh putting it into Ableton and just
finessing it in the program itself
are you we need to barter
yeah see I teach you on a real and you
could teach me Ableton all right this
sounds like a good deal
that's legit though I mean
like
wind bush is the guy for learning unreal
he is part of How I Learned unreal and
he he just put out of course a free
course on his on his page
um
for you know unreal course for beginners
five would it five uh five episodes
um yeah it's called Android engine five
in five days so each day is about an
hour but cover you know like whole
magnitude of different stuff within
unreal from like real building to
character animation to Motion Graphics
so yeah there's a lot of stuff in there
I should probably actually do another
one based off of our conversation here
because I did do a tutorial where you
could use like midi controllers to
control stuff inside of unreal that's
pretty dope and they just did some
updates on that so that could probably
make for a pretty dope course like
trying to merge like the audio side with
unreal because there's a lot of cool
controller stuff you could do with that
dude like you can control lights that
way too right
everything like lights cameras
um yeah any parameter that you want like
if you can't do it with the interface
you can always blueprint it and kind of
brute force it but yeah I've seen um you
know dead mouse right the idiom DJ yeah
that's what he he practically uses
unreal for a lot of his live performance
stuff so he has unreal hooked up to his
whole you know MIDI controller there up
on stage and he's doing a lot of his
stuff real time as he's playing out his
music is pretty dope what the heck yeah
that's advanced level
yeah he's well he has like an
engineering programming background so he
he gets pretty crazy with it
yeah I know a lot of streamers as well
do crazy real-time like backgrounds or
basically virtual Productions these
further streams or things like that and
really is really expanding on those
things yeah yeah
dang that would be so cool to get into
but that I feel like that's just that
would be my life then at that point it's
like I just dedicate a year to making
the best stream possible
um it's sweet it sounds like fun but man
that's a that's a deep dive for sure but
you already have like 90 of the pieces
you need to complete that vessel because
you know 3D you know cinematography you
know unreal you know compositing you
just would need to learn how to do
compost sitting inside and real I feel
like you get like a pretty sweet setup I
don't know maybe I'm naive because I
haven't done it but I feel like you
could do it pretty easily yeah he's
pretty much there you just need a green
screen you pretty much that
yeah it'd be cool to do a live show
where like I record
things that happen here like
I build this set in a studio right and
then it gets a car runs through here
like it just breaks through and like I
get hit or something right but it's like
pre-recorded and it's a and then I come
out from like back here
and I step over all the junk and I'm
like it's all chill like that was a
close one and I have like I have like 10
La I have 10 la oh my God
I got nine lives
and I'm gonna die every time but I have
to get the art done before I die not my
death
that's crazy
um we always have the pre-recorded thing
your your actual live Studios with a car
there you just do a Texas switch that we
cut we trade to the same place and then
you perform From Below but there's a
trap door I fall into a spike pit or
something
um I have to find a link for it because
like the discovery or not Discovery um
The Weather Channel
their whole studio is on real based now
it is like they were doing like natural
disaster stuff just like you were saying
you know like you would have the host in
the middle of like all this stuff going
on like if they're talking about like a
like a hurricane or something it's like
trees are falling around them and you
know like the flood is raising up around
them and like it's pretty crazy and
they're like standing in the middle of
it and it looks like they're in the
middle of like this environment that's
just like crashing down all around the
lake it's pretty wild I gotta see if I
can find it here dude if the weather
channel did tutorials that would be
crazy
they need to because there are some Next
Level stuff with that like I was looking
at it like man how the heck did they
even do that like the camera is moving
you know like the real camera is moving
so everything is parallaxing with it but
um
that's pretty wild
um someone's got a question for you bun
bunthal uh as a dad or your kids
creative and how do you engage with them
in that creativity and how do you help
them through the same pitfalls
um if they do hit the same pitfalls as
yourself creatively
um yeah I would say my daughter more so
than my son but my daughter she's taking
up um
more doing like traditional cartoon or
cartooning you know where it's like
frame by frame animation which she's
become a really good at that like she
doesn't even use a computer like she
pretty much gets on her tablet and goes
to town but um he's kind of like me
she's like self-motivated and a
self-starter because I've offered to get
her classes and stuff like that and it's
just like no I'm just gonna do it and
figure it out myself and he's been doing
it for a couple years like he's a
teenager now but she's been trekking
ahead so
um I did what I can to try to support it
you know like keep her up with the
latest technology or get the software
that she needs to pursue it but um yeah
other than just trying to be there and
give them help where they need it I mean
that's all you could do because I think
part of being an artist is all about
self-discovery like that's where he kind
of it's like an adrenaline rush like
when you have like this
like these problems that are set of
fourth you know in front of you and then
you are able to kind of overcome that
problem and you just get like that kick
out of it and that's what keeps you
going at least for me so like seeing
them have that like aha moment I think
that's what keeps them going so try not
to get in the way of that but just also
try to give assistance where it's needed
you know
absolutely that sounds like it's like
the best way to go about it for sure
seriously yeah that's great
dang
let's see let's see we've got a couple
more questions here and then we can
probably wrap it up because I'm gonna
have to get to the weekly challenge
um
see let's see and if you guys have
anything too feel free to ask but I'm
just going through the chat here
I dropped this link in our Discord too
it looks like it's on Facebook so I'm
not sure if you could play it or not on
the kill
that Discovery Channel stuff
oh yeah I have it okay let's see
all right cool yeah this stuff is pretty
wild
there we go
yeah so all that stuff
what
I have to find it for you yeah no one on
Rose website they did like a whole case
study behind it but yeah they did some
really cool effects from real time there
yeah there's that one there cool dude
what
this is the Weather Channel real time
VFX so much fun it's just like you're
trying to make everything work live and
it looks like a little bit chunky but
too like
I don't know this is great it's really
fun
yeah it's just it's crazy like how much
they're getting behind it you know
because I can't remember the last time I
even watched The Weather Channel and
it's just like for them to put this
magnitude of effort into
yeah making something cool you know like
right there like that's that's pretty
wild you know
dude the weather channel has leveled up
geez
and they're acting and everything yeah
they're like interacting with the
environments and they have like fans you
know blowing on them to make it look
like they're really in there I mean it's
it's pretty cool
yeah that's so cool yeah that's awesome
it'd be sweet to get a system like this
I've always wondered how like
the NFL does it you know they have all
the stuff tracked on to them in real
time and
uh there's that there's that hockey
clip where like a giant hand came out
from like the ice it like broke through
you guys remember that oh yeah yep yep
that's crazy
um
just Unreal Engine in real time
on live TV yeah it's pretty sweet
they got a lot of special systems in
place though like you know the NFL
Network they use unreal but they have so
much at their leverage that they're able
to utilize like
we could probably do it on a smaller
scale but you know NFL that's
multi-billion dollar Corporation they
got a lot at their hands you know so
they have the top of the top Engineers
able to bang out any problems that they
come across you know in real time
yeah
uh there you go yeah Logan's in the chat
there's another unreal expert he says
the NFL has about 16 people and four
or UE I guess before unreal is running
at once
wow
that's serious
I know not to say it can't be done but
yeah
yeah I know that ilm were making their
own render engine for their uh stage
virtual production things so I mean
apparently they run into some limitation
with unreal or maybe it's about I don't
know but I know they were making their
own custom render engine and platform
and everything so we'll see we'll see if
they show anything
the public about that
yeah I Alum they have their own like on
R D departments I wouldn't be surprised
that they come out with something that
they build custom for them kind of like
Mandalorian was the big first case study
for doing unreal stuff in real time for
a live production and then I think on
the Mandalorian too
they scaled back on it a little bit I'm
not sure about the more recent shows
maybe that's where they're using their
own stuff in there but yeah I yell them
they're they're pretty tops when it
comes to that stuff
so
um
I think I'll ask I'll hit you guys with
one more question
um before we bounce out of here uh I'll
I'll let you guys go and then I'll do
the weekly the weekly challenge and
whatnot for uh for everybody in the chat
here but uh
what are you guys looking to do here as
the year wraps up
and before you go into next year like
what are your plans are you guys going
to take a break are you guys going to
you know yeah I guess I guess that's the
question are you are you going to take a
break are you going to make time for
yourself and what are you gonna do
um to prepare yourself
for next year
um Adam
do you have any plans
uh well I have an EP coming out next
Friday so oh shoot and take a break yeah
that's nice pretty soon yes yeah
um but you know I'll be going to see my
family for Christmas and that's always
like a really good
reset
so it's always a good time to
reflect and look ahead
heck yeah sweet
Mikhail what about you man Are You full
force going through uh through to the
break or what yeah I'm kind of taking
half a break because I'm going back home
to visit family and friends so that's
awesome but then I have exams after
Christmas and also I have some
freelancing to finish up so I'm gonna be
working as much but from home and making
time for family and friends it is kind
of a break yeah absolutely heck yeah
when Bush what are you what are you
gonna do at the end of this year to
prepare for next year
yeah probably just going to keep it
moving you know oh straight through this
cake yeah I think so
um at least on the YouTube side like I'm
still adoring um more stuff with Rococo
I kind of rekindle that stuff over there
with those guys so I have a another
tutorial that I've been working on with
um the smart sleep too yeah smart yeah
the second smart suit and the Rococo AI
that they just dropped so I'm doing like
a comparison tutorial about like when
did you say I and where to use the suit
and how they kind of differ from each
other that's um been pretty fun to put
together working with lavanya Sam and
Mark and those guys over there on that
and then also yeah yeah they're they've
been great I got to meet them at
siggraph actually up in Vancouver this
year for the first time which was cool
so yeah great group of people they came
to watch my talk funny enough I saw them
with the Rococo suits as I was up on
stage and I went to go see them and they
were gone by the time I got off stage I
went over to their booth and hung out
with them for a little bit so yeah great
group of people over there and then um
I'm also going to be tearing down my
office here
um for the most part and just kind of
doing a hard reset for 2023 so I love
doing like DYI type stuff like I built
that arcade that's behind me my son and
I built that a couple years ago so I
figured I'm kind of outgrowing my desk
here so I got like this big wood slab
like 85 inches or whatnot so I'm like
building my own standing desk again
using that and just kind of configuring
it to what I need it to be because uh
yeah I'm like running out of space here
so just really wanted to put that
project on on hold till the new year and
yeah I think that's going to be it so
I'm kind of documenting that process too
in case anybody else wants to like build
their own desk and see exactly how I did
it and I'm kind of tackling Cable
Management too because that's a big like
my room is basically a fire hazard at
this point it has so many wires so plugs
all over the place so it's like I really
wanted to pay close attention and really
give attention to detail to that type of
stuff so definitely something I'm going
to be working on for the new year
yeah man that stuff's important like
getting your office right uh I I know
Adam you like put up lights recently and
stuff made made your place feel nice yep
what's the difference you loving it
oh yeah dude uh you gotta you gotta love
where you work man you gotta
you gotta love where you work it's Gotta
feel like somewhere you're gonna spend a
long time because that's exactly what
you'll be doing yeah
you're sound paneling did you get that
like on Amazon because I I need some of
that too because I get a lot of echo
like my walls pretty much right here so
even though I'm on a short mic I still
have to do a lot of cleanup on the back
end I mean you could you could hang like
a quilt or something if you want to be
in a pinch but I got this sound paneling
um from a studio that closed down it was
like a Craigslist find from a long time
ago
yeah I I gotta do the same
honestly yeah
I found some stuff about Amazon but I
wasn't sure if he had like if any Brands
make a difference or if anything absorbs
sound better than others or if it
doesn't I think with these with the foam
in particular it doesn't really matter
what you get because it doesn't really
it doesn't really like block the sound
it's just like you know the sound
doesn't reflect back
you know like uh you kind of reduce the
echo so to speak in my opinion
I'm sure
yeah because when you when you pay more
you're just paying for a denser foam so
but this phone
I don't know
I was really trying to get rid of it in
a hurry so I don't really know what the
quality is but it does do the job
have you ever done like any crates or
anything like that
uh I've been to Studios that do the egg
crates and I think they work honestly
something's always better than nothing
when it comes to that yeah sound
reflection
you said you think they work or they
don't work
they do yeah okay something's always
better than nothing I mean I've been to
I've been in a studio where like the
soundproofing was just like an immense
amount of artwork on the walls like that
doesn't that that actually does
contribute to dampening the sound
yeah I I
I'm looking at ways to clean up my
office too for next year I love I don't
know I love that kind of stuff I have a
lot of crap all over the place so I'm
trying to do my best to
organize it and like the less stuff I
see I think the more I can focus so I'm
trying to clean it up as much as
possible and
hang some lights maybe because I have to
bust out the nice lights every time I
film and that's that's always a pain
it's like always like a day of filming
um so yeah I'm trying to
trying to re-haul
the office I'm also trying to re-haul
like finances too to be honest because I
I don't have a good grasp
on I'm about to say I don't have a good
grasp on my finances uh I I've been way
worse I've been way worse but um
I really I want to have a better hold on
it where it's like I can see exactly how
much I have
put back into this like to pay for
editors or pay for help because I really
do need it next year
um and I need to I need to know how much
that's going to be in order to like not
be stressed out like oh I'm not making
enough or I gotta keep working so that I
keep making money and it's like well
maybe I
you know I don't have to do maybe I
don't need to be as stressed out as I am
about it so that's one of my goals this
you know during break is to figure that
stuff out and then uh
I mean think about what I really want to
make next year I don't want to go into
next year making the same videos
um
I I want to mix it up I want to innovate
and do something
different
yeah I'm really feeling something
different whatever that means I don't
know
um does that mean I'm gonna be making a
bunch of pocket operator videos
um who knows yoga tutorials for a month
yeah that'd be that'd be crazy
um but we'll see I think it just comes
back to happiness I gotta you know gotta
be happy with it all so
um I'm gonna be doing a lot of thinking
over the break and and taking the time I
need before I come back making videos
doing challenges I gotta figure that
stuff out so
let me know if you do any pocket
operator live streams I'll jump in for a
jam session or something once I get it
figured out yeah let's get together when
you get yours let's get together and and
do a jam session we'll go through like
we'll figure it all out so that we know
the know the hardware and we'll just
have a good time and we'll go from there
yeah no look forward to it I've
definitely been down at rabbit hole on
YouTube of just looking at pocket
operator you know composers and seeing
what people are doing with it and it's
been crazy just seeing everybody kind of
daisy chain like a bunch of pocket
operators together to make a full
sequence so like it's pretty wild then
this guy's watching last night was
actually that's like hanging outside
like sampling stuff like he put it in
the middle of like wind chimes or put it
up to like next to like a woodpecker and
he's just like sampling all types of
craziness and making like songs out of
it and like man it looks it looks a lot
of fun yeah here we go check this out so
Griffin uh from Corridor he got me this
little music box so
assuming you hear this do you recognize
it
[Music]
yeah I'm not picking anything up yeah I
can't hear it you can't hear that period
the string can period maybe the people
hearing you through this work can't
here this is maybe maybe that gives it
away it says Spirited Away right so I
basically I took that
and then
put it on this thing put on the pocket
operator
[Music]
whoa
yeah
and then like you can you can just add a
bunch of stuff to it so ah so much fun
so much fun
I have to get one of those that sounded
so cool yeah yeah not that much they're
like like 60 80 bucks I guess depending
on the one you got like I got the Capcom
ones so I think they had a two for one
is like 150 bucks for both of them but
yep like I just like Mega Man is Street
Fighter so was happy to get that
soundboard on top of it yeah yeah
they're they're so sick
um Adam we I know we lost your camera
but can you still hear us are you still
in the chat
yeah I'm still here
all right cool cool we're gonna wrap it
up anyway
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a small break
like two minute break and I'm gonna get
back here and do the weekly challenge
with y'all but guys I I really really do
appreciate you coming in and joining me
for the last stream uh Mikhail it's
great to have you when Bush good to have
you back and Adam it was absolute
pleasure to have you join me dude um
yeah it was cool it's been a crazy year
um we've all been a part of each other's
year
um I think that's super cool it means a
lot that you guys came in and joined me
for this last stream so thank you guys a
lot and best of luck wrapping out the
year we'll be talking but uh yeah thank
you guys
yeah no thank you for the invite in nice
meeting you guys Adam and Mikhail
getting to see you in person it's so
much fun 100 yeah honor and privilege
thanks for having us Clint absolutely
guys we'll we'll be chatting over the
next few days I mean we'll be chatting
forever so
I'll let you guys go
wasn't there any signs oh I can't see it
but yeah
I feel it yeah exactly something like
what Mikhail did exactly yeah oh yeah
English as well
all right I'll let you guys go
um for everyone in chat I'm gonna be
right back and then we're gonna get
through the weekly challenge
announcement get those five winners some
honorable mentions and and we'll say
goodbye but thank you guys so much I'll
see you later have a good rest of your
year
all right thank you take care everybody
cheers you all be well later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we are doing it we're doing the last
weekly challenge review of the year of
2022. it's been two and a half years of
doing this which is freaking crazy
is man it's rare that I look back but
two and a half years of weekly
challenges
that that's freaking awesome and you
guys have kept this going we we just
recently like hit the 100th one I think
we're on like 110 or something at this
point
um but
you guys have leveled up so much over
that time and it's so cool to like be a
part of that with you guys and and see
everyone leveling up
they're learning and growing together
that's the thing right it's great it's
better with people it's definitely
better with friends all right so
let's get into it first up our first
winner I know he was in the chat is
wondrous
and this is uh what was it out of place
I think was the prompt
um and dude this is so freaking cool uh
kind of reminds me of the what is it
armored Core six or something uh that
the announcement trailer was dropped
it's basically like Mech Warrior of the
game it looks incredible totally reminds
me of this this is awesome I love your
lighting
um the way you color corrected this is
super cool you got the film grain going
uh and it feels very visceral there's
motion blur it's Center framed it's huge
it's awesome this it reminds me of like
the medieval version of a scene from uh
dang what was the name of that uh yakase
it was a Netflix show with lakeith
Stanfield
um and
uh what was in the flying Lotus did the
music so cool yeah it's like a bunch of
Samurai fighting robots and stuff
uh so congrats wondrous you killed it
you knocked it out next up we have who
is that dim car above
dude this one's great
I love this it feels
I don't know I feel like I can touch it
I can reach out and touch it I love the
shallow depth of field
um it looks like a fun phone background
actually
but it's like what the heck I love it I
love this so much
um
yeah your textures
your lighting
the way you color corrected it I I just
love everything about it I think you
killed it you did a fantastic job and
this might actually be the first time
you won a weekly challenge
um dim car yabov
so congratulations to you for winning
super cool stuff next up we have 3D Gala
yeah this I was blown away at the
photorealistic look you got going here
your trees and the specular highlights
on these trees dude what
and this is Unreal Engine too
I'm blown away by this absolutely Blown
Away
um and yeah there's some crazy
sci-fi pyramid thing in the middle of
this untouched Valley
this super cool man he killed it and the
the camera movement is perfect too I
it's very rare that I see photo real
renders like this of this level
um so I was absolutely blown away by
this congrats 3D Gala
um next up we got Marcus seam
this one is freaking weird
uh this this is definitely out of place
I think you win
what on Earth is going on here
um
is some baby Teletubbies with some alien
eggs and like a dance club
yeah uh your animation's perfect you're
creepy creepiness level is perfect very
out of place
um your materials are great
your lighting's great the idea is
absolutely absurd yeah congrats on the
win dude that's that's disturbing
and finally we have who's that scooty
scouty
this is great so at first glance you're
like well what's out of place about this
you know we see this in Marvel movies
all the time
and um the first thing that Drew me to
this was of course the render quality
the lighting uh the atmosphere of this
even the post-processing work is
fantastic but you said um
I believe it was Merlin Merlin was a
magician
and I think somewhere in your
description said that like lives forever
and you had this magician Merlin here
who is not in his time period
and I I love that I thought that was
awesome backstory to this beautiful
piece of art so congratulations scouty
for winning
not the last
weekly challenge of the year
but it's the last weekly challenge on
the live stream of the year
but we got honorable mentions to get
into uh genzu I'm trying to read yeah I
think that's again Zoo
um this was based off of an image that
you found like this is super cool
um I love this man this is very
beautiful I love
Urban exploration for this exact kind of
stuff if I were to come across this in
real life I would be blown away I'd be
taking a million pictures of it I'd be
making renders of it
um so you did a really really nice job I
thought it was super solid on the
foliage too I think the only note would
be
you know like that photo real render
the animated one that we just saw
you're catching like the highlights of
the grass and the and the foliage
in a really nice way so I would take a
look at that see if you can't catch a
little bit of those highlights on your
leaves next up we got first Vault
dweller
yeah this one this one hits hard dude
this is uh
this one's sad I must say this one is
very sad but I don't know if you were
going for that
but uh you know this this one hits for
sure I love your color palette and I
love the Simplicity of your composition
you know there could be some things that
uh that you work on like
trying to blend the seam between your
rock Assets in the sand because
technically it's not one big rock and it
just hits sand the one big rock breaks
down to sand so you'll see smaller and
smaller rocks off of the larger Source
rock until you hit sand
um so little things like that you know
maybe a few more sticks around or
something
um but generally I really liked this you
know watch out for the blown out sky
you definitely want to bring that down
but but I loved it I love the color here
and I thought the actual like the source
material here the store you have is
pretty crazy for out of place uh Elliot
is next
I mean this is great this is again just
hitting me in that like adventurous kind
of spirit I love Urban exploration
that's one of the things I love so much
about living in in Georgia
um Atlanta is just covered in trees it's
very old old city right so there's a lot
of spots like this you'll find in the
woods so it really brought me back and
I'd say the same thing here you know see
if you can't catch some specular
highlight on your foliage
um even you want to mess with a
translucency uh you can plug your Albedo
or your color map into translucency to
get the sunlight reflecting through
those leaves and definitely try and
catch some of the specular highlight on
them too so you can mess with your uh
with your roughness values if you add
like maybe 0.2.3 you'll start to really
see the highlights get caught there on
the on the foliage and of course you get
you do need to work the sunlight in a
specific way but
yeah see what you can do next up we got
Dylan
um this one okay so this one I I get
what you're going for you got Pokemon
cards at a poker tournament
um
yeah good good use of the prompt here
you got the anamorphic lens which you
can see by the bokeh
on the particles they're stretched out
vertical so that means you got that
anamorphic cinematic lens you got the
Cinematic aspect ratio but the only
thing is the angle man
I think you need to like boom up a
little bit and tilt down it's hard to
tell these are Pokemon cards and it's I
have no idea what is wrapped around that
Magikarp card I don't know what that is
so there's a little bit of like loss of
clarity on this one
that you really you don't want people to
ever be confused with
what you're in what what you're trying
to communicate
um whether that be
a scene in a movie or
a single image you want to try and
communicate your idea effectively so I
just want to see a little bit more of
that Magikarp card and that that'll sell
it immediately
next up we have Brew Boutique bratique
uh yeah this one's cool
I just love the character love the
composition
you're backlighting these characters to
bust out their silhouette so you really
tell who they are immediately
and
you know you did a great job
putting them in a I don't put in quotes
a Sci-Fi environment really it's just an
office but I think it's first off the
fact that the horse is inside is what's
throwing me off and the blue like the
bluish cool color tone you have going on
here it does a great job usually in
westerns it's all like hot and warm but
you mixed it with the blue here it just
makes it feel Cold and like you've ever
seen a Sci-Fi office and of course you
got the little time travel
poster on the left for the story which I
think is great but you did a great job
um next up we got Bean whipped
this one here so this one I liked I
thought you did a good job with the
rendering and everything and the
lighting
um I don't know if this one is is out as
out of place
like I I of course get what you're going
for but to me this just seems like a fun
dinosaur character hanging out and
having a good time
um I think we see a lot of
cute unique characters
um
you know especially animals turned into
characters in 3D art nowadays so it
doesn't seem as out of place maybe as
you as you were going for I don't know
if there was like
if you put this dinosaur next to other
dinosaurs that are normal dinosaurs
maybe you'd get more of that out of
place kind of vibe
um but I I really do like it I think
you're lighting a solid character is
cool
tubby buddy
it's next this one's great I love the
framing here
uh the lighting is freaking awesome and
actually does feel like a magazine ad or
something
or a TV ad
the only thing that's throwing me off
here is like the materials you can see
on the left side it's tiling a lot same
on the right side on the on the Rock
structures it's just the tiling material
and even the like
the the material and the textures on the
uh
like the flags of the boat I forget
exactly what they're called but
they're all stretched out you know so I
would definitely watch out for that
um next time but otherwise I love the
the sky you have is perfect the
lighting's perfect I really dig it color
is nice composition is nice
game Factory yo what's up
all right I thought this was great and
immediately as soon as I saw it I'm like
this is definitely out of place
um yeah it's a dude chilling in the
bathtub in a graveyard that uh that's
definitely out of place
you did a great job you got this one out
quick too I think you were one of the
first ones to submit
uh this week
so good work nice nice snowy little
scene
I think you've been working in unreal a
lot it's cool to cool to hear man really
nice Naz is next
um so you went
you you kind of took this uh on a
different angle which I really
appreciate I think your colors are
really cool I love that like
I don't know what would that be
pink purple with like a light blue
again I am colorblind but I'm doing my
best here uh you get some like very
almost pastel kind of colors and your
whole thing was like if you think
out of the box then you're out of place
I think it's what you wrote down I
thought it was an interesting Take On
The Prompt so I wanted to shout you out
and I thought you had a nice little
scene here
uh next we have metatrox
um you guys really like this one you
guys voted this one up on the Discord
server pretty highly
um I dig the idea yeah I totally dig the
idea it's tough to do a rainy wet scene
like that
um with a lot of people it's a lot of
detail
but you did a really good job you know
colored her umbrella different color
and I wonder what it would look like if
you actually had the people moving
faster and lowered the shutter speed so
it was almost like just a blur of people
but she was standing there I think it
would draw the eye a bit more to your to
your character in The Middle
um Kenny is next
yeah this one this one's cool like you
really took the story to Heart here and
did your best to communicate uh an
interesting character in an interesting
environment so you have a bunch of
soldiers
um you said at their new temporary
Outpost and this character just felt
very out of place
yeah I think
I think you did a pretty good job here
it's an interesting take on it it's a
difficult take on it
um to try and communicate all of that in
one image but
it's very interesting I thought you did
a good job I thought your framing is
nice I thought your lighting's pretty
good
um I'd probably try and work I I'd
probably move the character back a touch
so their feet aren't touching the very
bottom of frame
um you did a nice job framing them up
with that board in the background
um
and I'd probably update
uh their shirt and pant texture it looks
like rubber
so let's see what you can do with like a
normal map
um some sort of knit texture cloth
texture
next up we have Jack the hack
yeah okay so this is a similar one than
like the one we saw two like
two pieces of art ago
this character is going against the flow
um you know dressed Carefree
uh contrasted with the businessmen going
in the opposite direction yeah I mean
this is good
and oh dude that's interesting um
I just realized this you tilted the the
like the level the horizon line you
tilted it so that these the businessmen
are going uphill they're going it's an
uphill battle but this character is just
coasting
I love that that's that's a nice touch
really good stuff
uh Jack Bowman is next
this one is cool immediately feels out
of place right underwater
desk setup I dig it the thing that threw
me off on this one was just the
background the shapes are confusing it
took me a while to realize what was a
like a Rudder of a boat and a whale and
I think you need to split those things
up
um and and make their Silhouettes a bit
clearer
um the boat
yeah that's a tough one I don't know
where the rudder begins on the top right
like
I'm assuming it's the bottom of the boat
on the bottom right of frame and then
like the top right is the rudder maybe
you need to rotate it a little bit more
so you see the full outline of a Rudder
and then scale your whale down so like
we can see it's a full whale we get the
idea of a whale of a Rudder on first
glance as opposed to having a search for
it but
like I said at the beginning I thought
it was a really cool
immediate out of place render with the
desk underwater
and finally we have hahaha I think this
is Alo maybe that's what you go by on
the on the Discord
I loved this one this felt like a fun
game that I want to play I love the
overcast lighting the muted colors the
green the cyan with the red in there I
thought was really nice and there's
almost like a low poly kind of a look to
your cassette
and I dig it I thought you did a
fantastic job so
yeah congrats to you guys
I think you nailed it you guys did a
good job congrats on all that stuff on
all the art on the weekly challenge
we've been doing it
um for two and a half years that's a
long time very long time
how's everybody doing I'll hang out with
you guys for maybe another five ten
minutes and then I'm gonna get some food
I need it
ah that was nice
that was nice I I love Adam like I've
been friends with Adam for probably 15
years 16 years
uh if you were there for the stream you
heard he was the best man
at uh at our wedding
and um Wayne Bush yeah I've known
wimbush for a handful of years and we've
got to go to different conventions
together different shows together for 3D
um we hang out a couple times like he
came over we did some photo scanning
together place we play games together
too he's just a great guy and of course
Miguel solimante he's been on the
Discord server for a very long time
since pretty much
pretty close to the beginning so you
guys probably know sodomonte pretty well
um and he's been helping me with the
streams uh so it was really cool to have
Soto on as well for the first time super
cool
Logan am I working on a movie I'm
that's a tough question because I'm in
I'm currently writing a movie but I
hadn't
spent consistent quality time with the
script
in a number of months right now because
I've been too swamped with the YouTube
channel
um and I'm not happy about that yeah I I
really want to make a movie I want to do
a lot of things but making a movie is
such a big one for me but it's so hard
at the same time but I also have to keep
the channel going because that's my
that's my job at this point is how I'm
making income
so yeah one of my things next year is to
definitely make more time for that and
uh prioritize it
most definitely
because it's very important this is very
important to me
uh Edge you say you love the stream so
glad you got up for it dude that's
amazing it is early for you right now
yeah
do I have any big goals for next year
that I'd like to share
um
I have like hazy blurry goals I like I
said I want to prioritize
um
making time for this movie
I want to prioritize a morning routine
which I think is part of writing you
know writing time in the morning but I'm
not behind this computer
um I really want to knock my morning
routine out and get it nice I want to
set up my drum kit in the garage and mic
it
um so I can record some sweet beats and
maybe do some maybe do some music live
streams I don't know we'll see
that'd be awesome
um
what else you know I want to figure out
new stuff to do next year on the channel
I don't want to repeat the same year
like I know we've been doing tutorials
Unreal Engine like I'm not trying to
switch it up entirely I honestly don't
know what the answer is yet I need time
to think about it and I hadn't had any
time to think the whole year I have had
zero time to think
and I've just kind of been going off of
you know
what what I can do quickly and well
which right now is unreal environments
it's crazy like at the beginning of the
year I was learning all that stuff
and at the end of the year I feel like I
have a really nice routine for that
um and I I'm not to say that I'm like
ready to move on to the next thing and
ditch unreal environments but
um
yeah I
I guess that's like what wind Bush was
saying like we always want to do more we
always do when we want to do more
um
but I and like Adam was saying I need it
to be intentional I want to think about
why I'm doing the things I'm doing
um so I have a lot of thinking to do
over the break
um
scratch
they're asking do you ever reach a point
where you know your limit or your
potential or you always left wondering
yeah I mean
yeah I do Wonder like what would it be
like if I had pursued a music career
um instead of
instead of video like where what kind of
music would I be making
or if I didn't do this at all it was
funny it was very funny when I was at
camp mograph this year
I was more than happy to just be carting
people around on golf carts I was part
of the welcome committee so when you
guys show up I'm like What's Up hop into
my golf cart I'll give you the tour of
the grounds and I'll drop you off your
room at your room and I'll be making
runs back and forth uh
you know all day
and I loved it oh my goodness I loved it
because it was a truly a break for me I
got to be off of work I got to be off of
the computer I got to be off my phone
and I got to just drive this golf cart
around and play music that I liked and
talk with people and
that was amazing but then I thought
about it and I was like
what if this was my life and I was like
oh no what if I was just like a camp
counselor
what would that look like
and it's it's crazy because it's like a
part of me a part of me could be that
that could be me
um where that that's it that's all
that's all life is just being a camp
counselor I'm like dang that'd be crazy
I'm not saying I'm gonna be a camp
counselor I'm just I was just imagining
um but in terms of like
have I hit my
let's see what was the question
foreign
do you ever reach a point where you know
your limit yeah I I reached my limit of
what I can do on my own on this channel
this year I I can't do any more than
what I've done this year
uh by myself and I didn't even do it all
by myself this year I I still had
um soda monthly's help with the live
streams I had uh some of the moderators
help with uh getting the the community
challenges up and running
um I had help of an editor uh Justin he
helped me with the
parts of you know some edits here and
there
um and he's helped me with the brand
integration edits that's been helpful
um
yeah uh I got a business manager
for the first time who's helped me with
the emails and whatnot and dealing with
the clients and scheduling and
uh you know negotiating price and what
we can do and all that stuff and that's
been so helpful so
I've gotten a taste of what it's like to
have help
and I know I need more of it next year
so I'm trying to figure out ways to
you know
open up
opportunities and for other artists
whatever that means I I I'm still like
like I said I've had no time to think I
gotta think about all that stuff over
break
that list right it's a big list
um
so I might be reaching out for editor
help I might be reaching out for like
graphic artist help for thumbnails and
that kind of stuff
um
you know we'll see
um and as far as reaching potential like
I I can always be doing more
yeah I can always be doing more
so I don't think I've reached my
potential yet
um there's too many too many areas to
to grow in so
yeah I'm excited about that
um
see I'm going through and reading you
guys stuff here and we'll wrap this up
soon
Andra how long will I go on judging the
weekly challenges will I pass the judge
rule on to someone else in the future
well I can't judge them for my the rest
of my life I know that
um
I'm open to it but I'm also like
wondering you know
I want it to be right I I certainly want
it to be right
and I want the value I want you guys to
get good value out of it and and to
still have fun with it
um
so that's also another thing that I want
to do over the break is
everyone on the Discord server we've
been doing this Discord server for two
and a half years roughly and
I hadn't asked you guys like
what do you like about the server what
don't you like about the server how can
it be better
what do you use it for
um
you know like those kind of things I
that information is also valuable to me
and I want to build a list of questions
to ask you guys
um to get feedback and kind of
craft the server I'm not going to say
around that but it's valuable
information to just make it better for
everybody
um
so that's that's another thing that I
gotta do it's on the list absolutely
um
oh a lemon Speed Run challenge Channel
maybe that's what we'll do next year
that'd be crazy
foreign
he's young and he's in Houdini he's
working with nuke
um
yeah I really really enjoyed
working uh with sodomonte
and uh like I learned stuff from him
it's crazy I know I know he's listening
to everything I'm saying because he's
literally producing the stream right now
but like yeah I learned a lot of a lot
of little things from from sodomontay
and it's cool it's like yeah he's like
wait he's very young
um and he he's on it he is on it
so I think it's just it's I I'm seeing
there's so much value in that and I'm
like that's freaking awesome
um
yeah yeah super cool
but guys uh
I think it's time to call it I gotta get
some food y'all have been amazing thank
you so much for an awesome awesome year
it has been a crazy year it has been uh
a very eventful year we've done two
Community challenges together we've done
a weekly challenge every single week
this year
um
and you guys have come back and stuck
with it you know you've you came back
and you watched the channel and you keep
the channel going you keep it growing
you guys are helping me pay the bills
you're helping YouTube push my videos
out there on the recommended
uh algorithm like that that
certainly would not be able to do this
if it weren't for you guys so I I thank
you thank you thank you so much uh for
coming back and hanging out every single
uh I guess every two weeks at this point
but keeping the Discord server live and
active y'all are amazing thank you I got
one more video coming out
um this year all right it's pretty much
going to be on Christmas like December
I might as well give you the good info
here hold on
uh
two weeks from now I'll make an event on
the Discord server
of when I'm gonna release this but it's
going to come out on Saturday the 24th
um it's my final Unreal Engine
environment breakdown of the year I'm
recreating a render from a hike I went
on it was completely it was like snowy
foggy windy icy it was crazy you
actually got a glimpse of the art at the
last eight seconds of the countdown of
this stream
so if you want to see it again you can
go check it out there but
I'm gonna be breaking that whole thing
down it's a loopable render too so I'm
going to teach you guys about looping
renders and how you can easily do those
in any software
of course I'm using Unreal Engine but
um
yeah that's the last bit of the year I'm
cranking on I just filmed it
I filmed it yesterday
last night
and it's all cozy it's got like the the
fireplace I got a fireplace going on the
laptop and then I also got like the
Christmas tree in the background I spent
hours lighting it all nice so I'm really
proud of how that you know that Talking
Heads portion came out but yeah look
forward to it
um I hope you guys have a great break
take a break please uh be kind to
yourself and uh
I I will do the same I'll see you guys
see you guys in 2023
um but uh yeah like I said Saturday the
24th y'all got the last video of the
Year have a good one thank you all so so
much
um
I'll catch you guys soon yeah thank you
you guys rock
peace out later
[Music]
okay
okay
[Music]